OKAY WELCOME BACK WE'RE GOING
TO START THE SECOND PART OF
TODAY'S HEARING RELATED TO. THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA EDUCATION
DURING COVID NINETEEN THE SECOND
PART OF TODAY'S HEARINGS ABOUT
OUR CHILD CARE AND EARLY
LEARNING PROGRAMS IN CALIFORNIA
IN SPECIFICALLY THE CLOSURES.
AND RELATES TO OUR ESSENTIAL
WORKERS. WE HAVE A IN ALL OF
FIVE INDIVIDUALS AND WE'RE
GOING TO ALLOW THEM TO- TO
START IN A FEW SECONDS BUT JUST
AGAIN THIS THE TOPIC IT'S ALL
BEEN OF EXTREME IMPORTANCE TO
THE LEGISLATURE IN THE ASSEMBLY
IS SUPPORTING OUR CHILD CARE IT
EASY PROGRAMS CERTAINLY THERE
AT THE BACK FOR WORKING IS WHO
ARE TRYING TO. WORKING BUT I.
WITH ITS NUCLEAR TO MAKE SURE
THAT ENTER CAN READY TO LEARN
AND SUCCEED SO WE NEED THESE
PROGRAMS NOW MORE THAN EVER AND
ONE THING THAT'S JUST VERY VERY
MINDFUL. FOR THIS TOPIC THIS
HAD WITH HEAR FROM THANK YOU
THIS. HUFFPOST I'M- AFTER A
VIRUS IN AFTER THE DAY CARES IN
THE US BECAUSE SO. MANY TIMES
WERE TALKING EXPAND. CHILD CARE
AT EASE. PROGRAMS IN CALIFORNIA
THE REALITY IS NOW IT'S ME MAY
HAVE TO FOCUS ON SAVING THEM-
IN ADDITION FOCUSING ON TODAY
HOW YOU CAN TAKE CARE OF OUR
SENSE OF WORKERS AS THEY'RE
GOING BACK TO WORK. SURE THAT
THEIR- PLACED. A DAY IN SOME
ACTUAL AT NIGHT- SO WITH THAT
WE WILL START WITH A- PANEL
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THE LA UPS ON THE LINE BUT I'M
NOT GOING TO PRESENT JUST BE
THERE FOR QUESTIONS DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION. THE CHILDREN'S
ALLIANCE OF LOS ANGELES WE HAVE
A REPRESENTS THE PLASTER COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION. AND WE
HAVE PRESENTED EVERY FROM CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS UNITED THE
PROJECT AS HE ARE YOU. YOU W.
AND APPS ME. SO WITH THAT-
LET'S ASK JESSICA BONES THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE OF STARS
OFF. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS- FOR HAVING ME
HERE TO DISCUSS THIS VERY
IMPORTANT TOPIC TODAY. I'M TO
DATE THE ADMINISTRATION IS
AUTHORIZED NUMEROUS EMERGENCY
PROGRAM CHANGES AND THE STATE
SUBSIDIZED. MEETING THE BY
LEAVING FAMILY EATS REIMBURSING
PROVIDERS FOR DAYS OF.
PROVIDING ALTERNATES TO
LICENSING TO OFFER TEMPORARY
PUBLIC CHILD CARE CENTERS FOR
CENTRAL WORKERS. ADDITIONALLY
THE ADMINISTRATION LEAST. AND
IN THE SB EIGHTY NINE FUNDS FOR
CHILD CARE FACILITY CLEANING
AND SET I THINK INCREASE ACCESS
TO TEMPORARY SUBSTANCE CARE.
PRACTICE CHILDREN IN LOW INCOME
ESSENTIAL. AS WE KNOW THAT THE
FEDERAL KERR'S APPROPRIATED
THREE POINT BILLION DOLLARS-
FOR THE CCD BG GRANT THE
FEDERAL CHILD DEVELOPMENT BLOCK
GRANT. OF WHICH THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION WE RECENTLY
LEARNED WAS ALLOCATED TO CAL.
FOR CODE NINETY. RESPOND I'M
FINANCE. WITH LOOK. APPRECIATE
THIRTY FOUR SPENDS AND DISCUSS
THE FOR THEIR- THANK YOU AND
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTION YOU MIGHT HAVE. THANK
YOU WILL CERTAINLY COME BACK TO
YOU A BIT LATER NOW LET'S HEAR
FROM- DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
ENGINE IN IT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THEIR NUMBER
MORGAN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION ON
BEHALF OF STATE SUPERINTENDENT
TAMMY GARMENT THANK YOU FOR
HOLDING THIS VERY IMPORTANT
TODAY ABOUT CHILD CARE SERVICES.
IN CLOSURE IS AN EVERY WE KNOW
THAT CHILD CARE IS AN ESSENTIAL
CRITICAL SERVICE FOR ESSENTIAL
WORKERS AND A BACKBONE OUR- ONE
SUPPORTS WORKING. WHILE ALSO
COMPANY HEALTHY CHILD
DEVELOPMENT WE WANT TO THANK
THE LOOKS. FOR GIVING US. TO
ADDRESS ACTUAL. REQUIREMENTS IN
THAT FISCAL YEAR WITH THE
PASSING OF ONE SEVENTY. AS WELL
AS SEVERAL THE GOVERNOR ACCEPT
ORDERS. IN LIGHT OF THE STATE
OF EMERGENCY OUR TEAM HERE HE
HAS THAT IN AS FAST AS HUMANLY.
I'M SURE THAT THERE ARE. FIELD
THE GUY THAT IT NEEDS AT. ALSO
TO WORK WITH OUR PARTNER TO
ADDRESS THE IMPACT AND I CAN'T
HONORED FOR. IN YEARS. TO DATE
WE'VE RELEASED IT MANAGED. WELL
ATTENDS WITH SEVERAL MORE IN
THE QUEUE. WE'VE ALSO DEVELOPED
NUMEROUS FAQS AND HELD WEAPONS.
AS WE DEVELOP THIS GUIDANCE WE
PARTNER CLOSE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SIR. GOVERNOR AS WELL AS THE
VI<c.cyan> BEING RELIGIOUS STAFF</c>
MEMBERS ARE CON PARTNERS AND
THERE'S IN ABOUT THIS GUY IS TO
PROVIDE TO RECKON. IS STABLE
THIS OF THAT REAL EVEN CARE
YEAH AND ELENA FOUND EASIER
RECOVERY WE GET THAT POINT. THE
IN SERVING OUR PARK SENATE
QUESTIONS OF GOTTEN SO FAR.
AROUND HOW DID WE DETERMINE ANY
OF OUR NEED FOR THAT. AT OUR
UNDERSTANDING OF DEMAND FOR
CHILD CARE MIND ESSENTIAL
WORKERS OUR TEAM ANALYZE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AMERICAN COMMUNITY
SURVEY CENSUS DATA. AN
ESTIMATED ONE POINT SIX MILLION
CHILDREN OR OTHERWISE ELIGIBLE
TO RECEIVE SERVICES IN TWENTY
NINETEEN. SAM X. OF A MAN ARE
IN REQUIRE. WERE ALSO A FOR
EMERGING CHILD CARE DUE TO
THEIR PARENTS BEING SENT TO
WORK. IF THAT'S THE MERGING THE
HADN'T OCCURRED WE WOULD HAVE
ACTUALLY HAD MORE CHILDREN
ABOUT 62% SIX MONTHS WOULD BE
ELIGIBLE AND THIS DECREASE
DEMAND IS A REFLECTION OF THE
FACT THAT MEN WHO AREN'T FROM
FAMILIES OF ESSENTIAL WORKERS
ARE SHELTERING AT HOME. THOSE
CHILDREN THERE ARE ROUGHLY
EIGHT HUNDRED AND THIRTY
THOUSAND CHILDREN OF PARENTS
WHO WORK IN THE HEALTH CARE
PUBLIC HEALTH AND EMERGENCY
SERVICES SECTOR AND WHOSE
FAMILIES HAVE INCOMES BELOW 85%
STATE MEDIAN INCOME. AS I ENTER
85% OF THE S. NINE IS JUST
UNDER SEVENTY THOUSAND FOR A
FAMILY OF THREE. IN ADDITION TO
MEDIAN INCOME OUT REQUIREMENTS.
SEC ORDER AND FORTY SEVEN
TWENTY ANOTHER ONE POINT SIX
MILLION CHILDREN OF ESSENTIAL
WORKERS WHO DON'T MEET INCOME
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS. ARE
NOW ELIGIBLE FOR EMERGENCY
CHILDCARE AFTER ALL OTHER
PRIORITIES ARE. IT REMEMBER
THAT THERE WERE A LOT OF OTHER
PRIORITIES FIRST WE'VE ALSO
QUESTIONS AROUND FROM THE AND-
AROUND NONTRADITIONAL HOURS AND
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND WHAT THAT
NEED WOULD BE. WELL WE DO NOT
HAVE AN ESTIMATE OF THE NUMBER
OF CHILDREN ESSENTIAL WORKERS
ANY CARE VERY NON TRADITIONAL
HOURS WE DO KNOW THAT THE
PRESCHOOL DEVELOPMENT GRANT
NEEDS ASSESSMENT. FOUND THAT.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN TEN CHILDREN
UNDER FIVE IT DIDN'T ANALYZE
THAT NEEDED CARE DURING
NONTRADITIONAL HOURS BASED.
WORK SCHEDULE. SO AS WE MOVE
INTO THE DEBATE AND JUST
REMEMBER THAT A LOT OF YEAH AS
HE TRIED OUR STATE AND THE AND
FOR CHILD CARE. DEVELOPED
ESTIMATES TWENTY EIGHTEEN AT
THE MOST RECENT. ADDICTING
WORKS IN IS BECAUSE WELL ABOVE
THEY CAN BE NINETEEN. THIS OF
THE FAMILIES THAT ARE FOR AS ME
CARE MAY HAVE CHANGED INDUSTRY
OR MAY NO LONGER BE EMPLOYED.
ADDITIONALLY THAT DOESN'T
INDICATE WHETHER THOSE WORKING
AN ESSENTIAL INDUSTRIES AND THE
ABILITY TO CONDUCT THEIR
ESSENTIAL FUNCTION WHILE
WORKING FROM HOME. THE DATA
ALSO DOES NOT INDICATE WHETHER
THOSE WORKING AN ESSENTIAL
INDUSTRIES AFTER FOR OTHER
OPTIONS FOR CARE. AND WE KNOW
THAT RIGHT NOW A LOT OF
FAMILIES ARE. AND HAVING OTHER
SHELTER AT HOME WITH THEM AND
HAVING THAT. HOWEVER EVEN WITH
THESE CAP YES WE KNOW THAT
THERE'S A LARGE NUMBER OF
CHILDREN WHO CONTINUE TO NEED
CARE. AND THEY'RE LOOKING AT
THE ADDITIONAL FUNDS FOR
SERVING ESSENTIAL WORKERS WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
ADDITIONAL FIFTY MILLION THAT
THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE ALLOCATED TO CREATE
RATE THE ADDITIONAL ABILITY. TO
SERVE CHILDREN OF ESSENTIAL
WORKERS AND TO AT RISK
POPULATIONS. USING AN
ALLOCATION METHODOLOGY WE
ADDRESSED THE FIFTY MILLION FOR
AN ALTERNATIVE PAYMENTS
THOUGHTS ACROSS THE STATE BASED
ON THE NUMBER OF CHILDREN OF
ESSENTIAL WORKERS. LOOKING AT
THE NUMBER OF CHILDREN IN THE
ADDRESS POP. AS WELL AS
CHILDREN IN THESE. COUNTY
ACROSS. ABOUT THE STATUS OF
PAYMENT THEMSELVES WE ALSO KNOW
THAT WE'VE GONE DIRECT
CONTRACTING PROCESS WITH OUR
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAM SO
THAT THOSE PLANS ARE ON THEIR
WAY TO NON CONTRACT ALREADY IN
THEIR HANDS. IN ADDITION TO
WHAT I'VE JUST DESCRIBED WILL
BE ADVANCING ALL OF THEM 33% OF
THEIR FUNDING THAT WILL HAVE
ADEQUATE CASH ON HAND FOR ANY
ANTICIPATED. ROMANCE WE LOOK AT
OUR GUIDANCE FOR CERTAIN
ESSENTIAL WORKERS. GIVEN THE
LARGE NUMBER OF CHILDREN WHO
HAVE PARENTS THAT SENT TO
WORKERS OUR GUIDANCE ON THIS
CLARIFIES THE PROVIDER SHOULD
ONLY BE ENROLLING CHILDREN OF
ESSENTIAL WORKERS RISK
POPULATIONS IN CHILDREN WITH
SPECIAL NEEDS AT THIS TIME. IT
ALSO PROVIDES THE PRIORITY
ORDER FOR THAT FAMILIES SELF
CERTIFY THAT CHILDREN FALL INTO
THESE CATEGORIES TO BE SERVED
AND THE CHILDREN ELIGIBLE ARE
ONLY THE GUY ONLY COVERS
REACHING THIRTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY. THEY DO NOT LEAVE THE
TWELVE. I MEAN ARE. THIS
ENTERPRISE TO CONTRACTORS THEIR
FUNDS TO ALL CHILDREN EMERGING
CHILD AS WELL AS CONTRACTORS
USING THAT FIFTY MILLION
AUGMENTATION THAT THEY JUST
RECEIVED. SO AS WE LOOK AT
TRACKING PLY IN THIS ACROSS THE
STATE. I'M IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT PARENTS WHO ARE ESSENTIAL
ARE ABLE TO FIND EMERGENCY CARE
WE HAVE DIRECTED OUR LOW
RESOURCE AND REFERRAL AGENCIES
ARE ARE IN OUR COLLECTED UP
LIKE DATA ON WHETHER SUCH. A
HOME BASED PROVIDERS ARE. WITH
A BILL OF. ARE BUT WE TO OPEN A
TECHNO ASSISTANCE ARE SOME. OR
CLOSED AND WILL REMAIN CLOSED.
THIS STATE IS WORKING ON
CONNECTING ALL THE OUR INNER
AGENCY DATABASES SOMETHING
CALLED MY CHILD CARE PLAN. I
DATABASE TOLD ABOUT BY THE
CALIFORNIA RESOURCE AND
REFERRAL NOW IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH CD AND OTHER PARTNERS.
ONCE THIS IS COMPLETE THAT
ANIMAL. BUT THE STATE LEVEL FOR
HELP MAKE POLICY DOES THAT.
BRING MY- WE NEED NOT BECAUSE
WHICH IS THAT THE CAL
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
HAS BEEN DOING EMPIRE WITH REST
OF I'M WE LOOK AT STEP. AT WE
CONDUCTED A SURVEY BETWEEN SIX
AND APRIL EIGHTH FOR BOTH OUR
EARLY MORNING HERE DIRECT
CONTRACT THE FIGHTERS. THE TEAM
MORE INFORMATION ABOUT WHICH
PROVIDERS ARE OPEN. THE 54%
THAT RESPONDED WE HAD 70% WHO
ARE OPEN AND PROVIDING CARE AS
OF EARLY APRIL. ADDITIONAL 18%
INDICATED THAT THEY PLAN TO
OPEN. OR WELL. AFTER WE REALLY
GUIDANCE ON AND ROLLING WORK.
ASIAN WE'VE HEARD MANY MORE
DIRECT CONTACT PROGRAMS ARE
WILLING TO NOW OPEN UP SO THAT
THEY CAN ALSO BE PART OF THE
SOLUTION IN SERVING CHILDREN
AND ESSENTIAL WORK. WE WILL
CONTINUE TO COLLECT DATA TO
MONITOR THIS AVERAGING XIN. ONE
OF THE KEY THINGS FOR US ALL TO
REALIZE AND THAT WE'VE HEARD
FROM OUR STAKEHOLDERS IS THE
ISSUE OF STABILIZING PROVIDERS.
ONE OF THE- IN TO STABILIZE THE
CHILD OR SUPPLY AND ENSURE
CHILD CARE PROVIDER SOLVENCY.
IS TO ISSUE GUIDANCE IN THE
PROVIDERS CAN STILL BE PAID
EVEN IF THEY ARE. THIS ALSO
STATES THAT CLOSE FOR BUYERS
WILL HAVE TO CONTINUE TO ENGAGE
FAMILIES WHILE THEIR PAY. AS
THIS WORKS A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENTLY. DEPENDING ON
WHETHER OR NOT IT'S COMING
THROUGH OUR VOUCHER SYSTEM ARE
DIRECT CONTRACTS SYSTEM IT DOES.
CONTRACTS SYSTEM ACTUALLY HAD
CHILDREN IN A PROGRAM INCLUDING
A CENTER OR A FAMILY CHILDCARE
HOME AS PART OF A NEW CHAPTER
EDUCATION NETWORK. THE SECOND
DOOR THE CHILDREN RECEIVE A
VOUCHER FOR INTERNET PAYMENT
CONTRACTOR AND CAN USE THAT
VOUCHER TO CHOOSE THEM A PLACE
OF THEIR SET I'M CHOOSING A
CENTER OF HOME OR LICENSE
EXEMPTS PROVIDER THREE OKAY GET.
OUR CONTRACT IN DOWNTOWN
PROVIDE ARE THAT ARE PART OF
INFECTION MAY CONTINUE TO BE
PAID FOR THE REMAINDER OF THE
YEAR IF THEY'RE CLOSED. HE'S
PROVIDERS ARE REQUIRED TO
SUBMIT A PLAN TO ASK AND HOW
THEY WILL CONTINUE TO ENGAGE
FAMILIES BY THEIR CLOTHES.
WHICH INCLUDED. AT PROVIDING
ONLINE RESOURCES AND ACTIVITIES
FOR THEIR CHILDREN AT HOME IN
THE ENGAGEMENT EARLY LEARNING
ACTIVITIES WE'VE HEARD OF
VIRTUAL CIRCLE TANKS AND STORY
TIMES. OUR PROVIDERS ARE
DROPPING OFF BOOKS IN MULTIPLE
LANGUAGES AND DOING READ ALOUD
WITH THE CHILDREN VIRTUALLY AS
WELL AS SUPPORTING SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL RELATIONSHIPS.
CONTINUE WITH THEIR- CHILDREN-
TEACHERS AND THEIR PEERS. AS
WELL AS INCREASING THEIR
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT. FOR
ABOUT YOUR SIDE OF THE HOUSE IS
CENTER IN FAMILY CHILDCARE
LICENSE EXAM PROVIDERS WHO ARE
RECEIVING A VOUCHER FROM MY
FAMILY MAY CONTINUE TO BE PAID
FOR UP TO THIRTY CALENDAR DAYS
STARTING ON THE FIRST DAY THE
PROVIDER CLOSED. THIS APPROACH
IS A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT THAN
OUR DIRECT CONTRACTED PROGRAMS
AS ABOUT YOUR ACTUALLY FOLLOWS
THE CHILD IN THE FAMILY IF THE
PROVIDER CLOSES AND THE PROVIDE
FAMILY DECIDES TO ATTEND A
DIFFERENT PROVIDER. AND ABOUT
YOUR FOLLOWS THEM TYPICALLY TO
THE NEW PROVIDER. AS OLD AS
FAMILIES ORIGINAL CHILDCARE
PROVIDERS WERE CLOSING AND
THESE NEED TO SWITCH TO
SECONDARY PROVIDERS TO CONTINUE
THEIR CARE. WE HAVE FOR THE
DAYS OF DUAL PROVIDER PAYMENTS
TO ENSURE THAT WAS DEVELOPED.
PROVIDES DIRECT CONTRACTING IS
DECIDING TO SHELTER IN PLACE
NOT PROVIDER WILL STILL RECEIVE
THE FUNDS TO HOLD THAT CHILD
SPOT. THESE POLICIES STABILIZE
THE CHILD CARE SUPPLY AND
ENSURE THAT CHAPTR PROVIDERS
CAN STAND BUSINESS AS WELL AS
PAY THEIR STAFF UNTIL DURING
AND AFTER THE RECOVERY. SO AS
WE MOVE FORWARD WITHQUALITY
ACTIVITIES WE REALLY HAVE AT
SOME OF OUR CCD AFTER CHILDCARE
AND DEVELOPMENT FUND QUALITY
INVESTMENTS TO ENSURE THAT OUR
PROGRAMS CAN BEST SUPPORT THOSE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE SERVING OUR
ESSENTIAL WORKERS. SAID THEY
SHIFTED FROM IN PERSON
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT TO
VIRTUAL. TEAM VIRTUALLY HOLDING
COMMITTEES OF PACKED THAT'S
VIRTUALLY AND REALLY FOCUSING
ON THINGS THAT JUST TRAUMA
INFORMED CARE AS WELL AS
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AND
HEALTH AND SAFETY PRACTICE.
WE'VE SEEN A REMARKABLE
INCREASE IN OUR CALIFORNIA
EARLY CHILDHOOD ONLINE PLATFORM
THAT WE HOSTED A DEPARTMENT.
THAT WE TYPICALLY HAVE FIVE
HUNDRED USERS PER MONTH SINCE
MARCH FIRST WE HAD OVER TEN
THOUSAND NEW USERS JONES JOINT
SECO. WITH USERS REFLECTING OUR
WORLD COMMUNITIES AS WELL AS
OUR URBAN AND LA NOW BEING HOME
TO AYE THIRD ALL SPEAK OF
USERS. WE'VE SEEN SOME OF OUR
INVESTMENTS SUCH AS QUALITY
COUNTS CALIFORNIA. ARE EACH
TWELVE REALLY WRAP AROUND OUR
PART COMES TO PROVIDE SUPPORT.
ME AS WELL AS SUPPORTING STAFF
TO REALLY UNDERSTAND AND
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL STATEMENTS
TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
ADDITIONAL COST. WE SHARED WAS
A MEMBER CONTRACTORS THAT HAVE
THE ABILITY THAT THEY COULD USE
SOME OF THEIR FINDS TO PURCHASE
SUPPLIES STAR ARE IN OUR
AGENCIES AS WELL AS LOOKED
HEALTHCARE ANY COUNCILS. AT
MOVING FORWARD THE OTHER THING
THAT WE REALLY APPRECIATE THAT
IS THE FIFTY MILLION YOU'VE
PROVIDED TO SUPPORT THE
CLEANING SUPPLIES FOR CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS. THESE
ALLEGATIONS ARE IN THE PROCESS
OF BEING MADE TO OUR RESOURCE
AND REFERRAL AGENCIES IT WILL
THEN BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
ALLOCATING THESE FUNDS TO BOTH
LICENSED AND LICENSE EXEMPT
PROVIDERS. IN THEIR SERVICE
AREAS. BOTH PROVIDERS ARE
SERVING SUBSIDIZE CHILDREN AS
WELL AS PRIVATE PAY CHILDREN
CAN ACCESS THESE FUNDS. NUMBER
FINALIZING THE GUIDANCE FOR OUR
NORTH HONEST THE ALLOCATIONS
FOR AIR ALREADY OVER THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE SO THAT
THEY CAN MAKE THEIR WAY TO.
SHORTLY HE'S FINE COMBINED WITH
THE FOUR MILLION THAT FIRST
FIVE CALIFORNIA'S ALREADY
PROVIDED TO THE FIELD AS WELL
AS OUR REPURPOSE FUNDS FROM A
QUALITY PROJECTS. IN HELP OUR
PROVIDERS ACCESS ADDITIONAL
SUPPLIES AND RESOURCES THAT
MAKE IT EASIER FOR THEM TO
OPEN. AND RE OPEN AND PROVIDE
EMERGENCY CHILD CARE. AT THE
LAST THING THAT I THINK I WILL
COVER IS AS WE ADDRESS THINGS
IS LOOKING AT OUR AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS. AND WE JUST READ THE
DEPARTMENT RELEASED AN
ANNOUNCEMENT ON MONDAY THAT OUR
AFTER SCHOOL EDUCATION AND
SAFETY ARE ACES AS WELL AS OUR
TWENTY FIRST AT EIGHT. AND
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY ASKED THAT
ARE GOING STANDING THERE GRANT
SAID THAT DURING THE SUMMER
THEY CAN REALLY GIVE IT TO GO
MORE DEEPLY ON THE SUMMER
LEARNING LOSS. I YOU KNOW ARE
AT THE END OF THE PROGRAMS.
THANKS THEIR STAFF COME FROM
THE COMMUNITY AND THEY PROVIDE
A GREAT DEAL OF SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL SUPPORT AS WELL AS
DEEP THIRTEEN THE HELP IS NOT
THAT I THAT HAPPENS RIGHT
COMMUNITIES. SPRING CLOSING AS
WE MOVE THROUGH THIS
CHALLENGING TIME WE WANT TO
ASSURE YOU THAT WE'RE DOING
EVERYTHING IN OUR POWER TO SURE
STABILIZATION FOR FAMILIES
PROVIDERS WHILE ADDRESSING THE
URGENT NEED THAT ESSENTIAL
WORKERS. REACHED REALLY BELIEVE
THAT THE STEPS WE'RE TAKING
TODAY ARE WORKING TO SAFEGUARD
CALIFORNIA'S CHILD CARE TO THE
EXTENT POSSIBLE. THAT THERE ARE
OTHER FACTORS THAT REALLY AN
IMPACT ALL OF THIS AS WELL THE
RESEARCH SPANNING THE ENTIRE
ECONOMIC SITE WELL UNDERSCORES
THE INVESTMENT IN CHILDCARE
ROSE THE ECONOMY IMPROVES JOB
QUALITY THAT'S CHILDREN UP TO
EAT WILL CONTINUE TO RELEASE A
REVISED GUIDANCE AS THE
SITUATION CHANGES. I THINK ALL
OF YOUR SEAT AND IT SEEMS TO US
DAILY AND BE AS RESPONSIVE AS
POP SO BOBBY NEAT DURING THIS
EMERGENCY. THANKS FOR
RECOGNIZE. IN THIS. YOU AND I.
ANSWER ANY QUESTION YOU MIGHT
HEAR. OKAY THANK YOU WILL SEE
COME BACK TO YOU BIT LATE NEXT
WE HAVE DOCTOR MICHAEL NICK WE
THE CHILD CARE A LOT OF LOS
ANGELES. MICHAEL THANK YOU FOR
INVITING ME TO SPEAK ON BEHALF
OF THE CHILD CARE ALLIANCE OF
LOS ANGELES- I'M MICHAEL ON
THAT GUY AND THE BOARD
PRESIDENT- OF THE ALLIANCE THIS
YEAR. AND ALSO THE PRESIDENCY
OF THE CHALK RESOURCE CENTER
WHICH OPERATES IN NORTHERN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY AND ALMOST ALL
OF US AND OF SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY. I'M GONNA TALK BOUT-
IN PARTICULAR WHAT THE ARE NOT
OURS THE AP RESPONSE HAS BEEN
IN LA. BUT I WANT TO MAKE IT
CLEAR THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE
ARCHER MARSHALL THE MARKET
LARGER. RESPONSE WORKING WITH
RAY. THE SAME CAL EIGHT AND
PRIVATE. THAT HAVE BEEN FOR
ALMOST TWO MONTHS TO BRING A
COUNTY WIDE CHILD PLAN CONTROL.
WE'VE SEEN ON THE- WE'VE NEED
THE REASON RESOURCES TO. RATING
IN. YOU KNOW I COUNTY WE HAVE
EIGHT OUR HOURS ADMINISTERING
CHILDCARE SUBSIDIES INCLUDING
STAGE ONE STAGE TWO STAGE THREE
THE ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAM
IN AN ADDITIONAL THREE AGENCIES
THAT ARE NOT OURS BUT ALL
ADMINISTER ALL THE SUBSIDY
PROGRAM. TERROR AGENCIES BELONG
ALLIANCE THAT WAS ESTABLISHED
TWENTY YEARS AGO TO POOL
RESOURCES PROVIDING CONSISTENCY
ACROSS PROGRAMS. IN CREATING A
SINGLE ENTRY POINT FOR THE
COUNTY AND THE STATE. MANY
YEARS AGO I IT'S CREATED A
WEBSITE AND TOLL FREE NUMBERS
SO THAT FAMILIES COULD FIND
THEIR LOCAL LEARN ARE. IN COULD
SEAMLESSLY MOVED TO THEIR LOCAL
SERVICE PROVIDER. LOCAL ARE NOT
COUNSELOR CAN PROVIDE THEM WITH
REFERRALS DIRECT THEM TO SIGN
UP FOR THE AUTUMN OF PAYMENT
PROGRAM QUIRK VICE THEM ON HOW
TO ACCESS THE TEN OF FUNDED
CHILDCARE PROGRAMS. ANDERSON SO
SELF SERVICE THROUGH OUR
WEBSITES. WHEN THE PANDEMIC TO
HAVE THEM IT STRUCK LA COUNTY.
CHILD CARE FOR ESSENTIAL
WORKERS BECAME PACKED
PARAMOUNT. ALL EIGHT GARNER'S
HAD BEEN CONTACTING EVERY
LICENSE PROVIDER TO DETERMINE
AVAILABILITY TO CARE FOR THE
CHILDREN OF MEDICAL STAFF IN
PARTICULAR FOR THE LAST SEVERAL
WEEKS. AS OF FRIDAY APRIL
TWENTY FOU. 56% OF OUR LICENSE
FAMILY PROVIDERS WERE OPEN. 22%
OF OUR SAMPLE CENTERS ARE OPEN.
ONLY 10% OF OUR S. P. P. AND C.
C. T. ARE CONTRACTED SITES WERE
OPEN. WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT
NUMBER OF CARE PROVIDERS WHO
WILL BE ABLE TO RETURN OF ONE
FIFTY THIS CRAP THIS IS OF. WE
ADDED ENHANCED ROSE TO OUR
ARMED SERVICE CAN. WRITE ON
APRIL TENTH. YEAH CONTACTS US
AND WE ARE ABLE TO CONTACT
PROVIDERS THAT WE KNOW ARE OPEN
TO SECURE A SPOT THERE'S NO
ADDITIONAL FUNDING. PUSH THIS
IT'S JUST PART OF WHAT WE CAN
OFFER THROUGH OUR ON OUR
COUNTRY. TWO WEEKS AGO MADE A
PRESENTATION TO THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION. WE HAD MORE THAN
FIFTY HOSPITAL REPRESENTATIVES
ON THE CALL. SINCE THEN WE'VE
RECEIVED A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
ONE CALLS FOR MEDICAL WORKERS.
AND HAVE RECEIVED AND HAVE
COMPLETED FIFTY FIVE ENHANCE
REFERRALS RIVERSIDE FOR STAFF
ACROSS THE COUNTY IS LEE IS
HONEST THE HOSPITAL HR
DEPARTMENTS AND EXPECT THE
NUMBER OF ENHANCE REFERRALS TO
CONTINUE TO RISE. BUT THEIR
PRESENTATION TO THE
PHILANTHROPIC COMMUNITY ON THE
NEED FOR SHORT TERM SUPPORT.
AND HAD MORE THAN FIFTY PEOPLE
ON THE CALL. WE'VE HAD A NUMBER
OF CONTRIBUTION SINCE THEN BUT
NOT NEARLY ENOUGH TO MAKE A
DENT IN THE DEMAND FOR
SUBSIDIZED CARE. WITH DONATIONS
DIAPERS CLEANING SUPPLIES AND
MASKS AND WE'RE REALLY LOOKING
FORWARD TO THE OUR PORTION OF
THE FIFTY MILLION THAT WAS
ALLOCATED BY THE STATE FOR THIS
PURPOSE. WE ALSO HAVE TO CHOP
TO STORE WE DO GET THE SUPPLIES
PROVIDERS ARE ALSO COMPLAINING
TO US. THAT THE STORES THAT ARE
OPEN WILL NOT LET THEM SHOP
DURING OUR SET ASIDE FOR THE
WORKERS. CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
ARE AS ESSENTIAL AS MEDICAL
WORKERS IN THIS PANDEMIC AND
SHOULD BE RECOGNIZED AND WE
WOULD ASK THE GOVERNOR TO
ACTUALLY MENTION THIS IN ONE OF
HIS BRIEFINGS. CITY ABOUT A IS
DEVELOP EMERGENCY CENTERS AT
SOME OF THE RECKONED PARK SITES
USING EMERGENCY WORKERS AS CARE
GIVERS FOR SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN.
THEY ARE OBSERVING THE
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH SERVICES.
SOME HOSPITALS HAVE CREATED POP
UP SITE STAFFED BY VOLUNTEERS
BUT WITH FOUR THOUSAND SPACES
AVAILABLE IN LICENSE FACILITIES
WE RECOMMEND USING CARE GIVES
EXPERIENCE WITH GROUPS OF
CHILDREN. WE ALSO NOTE MANY
ESSENTIAL WORKERS NEED CARE FOR
TWELVE HOUR DAYS AND WILL
CHOOSE FAMILY AND FRIENDS AND
NEIGHBORS TO PROVIDE CARE CLOSE
TO HOME. WHEN CHALLENGE THAT WE
HAD IS WAITING FOR THE FUNDING
FOR THOSE ESSENTIAL WORKERS WHO
HAVE HAD A NEED FOR FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE. WE KNEW THAT THE
FEDERAL STIMULUS CARES THAT
ALLOCATED FUNDING FOR CHILD
CARE FOR CENTRAL WORKERS BUT IT
TOOK THE US DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH. AND HUMAN SERVICES
OFFICE OF CHILD CARE SEVERAL
WEEKS TO PROVIDE ALLOCATION
AMOUNTS. AND GUIDANCE TO THE
STATE. AND WE'VE SEEN YET TO
SEE ONE DOLLAR HIT THE STREETS
SO I'M GLAD TO HEAR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THEY'RE
WORKING ON. WE ALSO KNEW THAT
THE FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS HAVE
BEEN ALLOCATED FOR CHILD CARE
THREE BEACH ONE SEVENTEEN BUT
DID NOT FIND OUT HOW THAT MANY
WOULD BE ALLOCATED UNTIL FRIDAY
APRIL SEVENTEENTH. FOR JUST C.
C. R. C. MY AGENCY WHICH SERVES
BOTH THE NORTHERN END OF LA
COUNTY IN ALMOST ALL OF SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY. 75% OF
PARENTS CURRENTLY RECEIVING
SERVICES THROUGH THE
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAM ARE
CONSIDERED ESSENTIAL WORKERS.
IN SURVEYING ARE TWENTY TWO
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED PERSON
WAITLIST. 66% ARE AN ESSENTIAL
SERVICES IN 41% ARE IN MEDICARE
RIGHT MEDICALLY RELATED
SERVICES. WE'VE ALSO WITH OTHER.
AND ONLY 72% OF THEIR WAITING
LIST ARE ESSENTIAL WORKERS IN
SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY 73% OR
ESSENTIAL WORK. FOR MY AGENCY
IF EVERY MEDICAL WORKERS CHILD
WOULD RECEIVE CHILD CARE. WE
WOULD HAVE TO SERVE SIXTEEN
THOUSAND CHILDREN. AT A
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER MONTH WE
WOULD NEED ALMOST SIXTEEN POINT
SIX MILLION DOLLARS A MONTH TO
FILL THE NEED. SO WE RECEIVE
SIX MILLION DOLLARS SHADE UNDER
THAT WHICH WOULD FOR PHIL 18%
OF THE NEED OF MEDICAL WORKERS.
SO IF EVEN ONLY ONE THIRD OF
THE CHILDREN NEEDED CARE WE
WOULD NEED ABOUT FOUR POINT
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS A MONTH.
ON THURSDAY APRIL TWENTY THIRD
WE STARTED INFORMING PARENTS
THAT WE COULD NOW START ROLLING
ESSENTIAL WORKERS INTO THE
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAM. IN
JUST THE FIRST FEW DAYS MY ONE
AGENCY RECEIVED NINE HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY FIVE APPLICATIONS IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY IN ANOTHER
FOUR HUNDRED AND SIXTY IN SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY. THE DEMAND
FOR CHILD CARE SUPPORT WELL
THAT'S DISAPPEAR IN THE NEW
FISCAL YEAR. THE SCHOOLS CLOSED
UNTIL. AB JULY MAYBE AUGUST
MAYBE SEPTEMBER MAYBE LONGER.
SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN MAINTAIN
FULL TIME CARE NOT JUST AFTER
SCHOOL RANCHES DEBATING THAT
PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS AND EVEN SHE
QUE PROGRAM SENSIBLE CAMPUSES
MIGHT BE CLOSED BECAUSE OF THE
ADDED DEMAND. THAT WILL LEAD TO
THE DEMAND- WE'RE HEARING FROM
SUMMER CAMPS THAT WERE ON
COLLEGE CAMPUSES THAT THEY WILL
BE CLOSE THE SUMMER THAT ALSO
ADDS TO THE DEMAND. THERE MAY
BE SOME SHORT TERM SAVING. FOR
A P. PROGRAMS BUT NOT ENOUGH TO
ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF JUST THE
MEDICAL WORKERS. THE ASSUMPTION
THAT PARENTS HAVE LOST THEIR
JOBS AND CAN STAY HOME WITH
THEIR CHILDREN HAS HAD VERY
LITTLE IMPACT ON THE DEMAND
THAT WE'RE SEEING. FOR
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAMS.
REALLY PROVIDING THE SUPPORT TO
THE ON HERALD UNHERALDED
MEDICAL WORKERS WHO CLEAN THE
HOSPITALS THE FOR THE BOTTOM AS
THE RECEPTIONIST NURSES
ASSISTANCE THE TECHNICIANS. ALL
OF THE LOW WAGE EARNERS IN THE
MEDICAL FIELD WERE PRIMARILY
WOMEN OF COLOR. JUST TO NAME
SUPPORT JUST TO MAINTAIN
SUPPORT FOR ESSENTIAL MEDICAL
WORKERS AT THE CURRENT FUNDING
LEVEL OF TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS A MONTH. FOR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WE WOUD NEED THREE
MILLION DOLLARS STATE WIDE FOR
THE NEXT YEAR. THIS IS PRETTY
CLOSE TO THE THREE HUNDRED AND
FORTY THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS A STATE WAS
ALLOCATED THROUGH THE CARE
CENTER. HOWEVER IT DOESN'T COME
CLOSE TO THE NEED OF ALL THE
ESSENTIAL WORKERS. FINALLY I
WOULD POINT OUT THAT THERE ARE
HUNDREDS OF LICENSED CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS WHO REMAIN OPEN
DURING THIS CRISIS AND STRUGGLE
TO REMAIN SAFE. WHILE PROVIDING
SERVICE TO THOUSANDS OF
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES. AND I
WANT YOU GUYS ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES ACROSS THE STATE WHO
REMAINED OPEN. UP VIRTUALLY
THANK. RALPH IS FIVE DAYS AFTER.
FOR NOTRE. IS DUE TO THE CA.
ADAPTABILITY AND CAN DO SPIRIT
TO SUPPORTER PROVIDERS. ARE
ESSENTIAL WORKING PARENTS
CALIFORNIANS CHILDREN. YOU AND
I REMAIN ON THE LINE. OKAY
THANK YOU NEXT WILL GO TO
CATHERINE COINS WITH THE
PLASTER COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION. HI I AM HERE ON
BEHALF OF GALLAGHER BILLION
WHEN HE GOT FASTER COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS AND
I'M VERY GRATEFUL FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE SOME OF
OUR EXPERIENCES WITH EMERGENCY
CHILDCARE PLASTER COUNTY I
BELIEVE THAT OUR EXPERIENCES
ARE SIMILAR TO MANY COUNTIES.
THE STATE. YOUR TAKES PLACE THE
MIX DELIVERY SYSTEM OF FAMILY
FUNDED AND PUBLICLY FUNDED
CHILDCARE. INTERCONNECTED
INTERDEPENDENT WHEN ONE PART OF
THE SYSTEM IS IMPACTED ALL
PARTS OF THE SYSTEM ARE
IMPACTED. IN ORDER TO INCREASE
THE AVAILABILITY OF CHILDCARE
WE HAVE TO THINK ABOUT ALL
PARTS OF THE SYSTEM SCHOOL
DISTRICTS COUNTY. OFFICES OF
EDUCATION FAMILY CHILDCARE AND
INFORMAL CAREGIVERS SUCH AS
FAMILY MEMBERS FRIENDS AND
NEIGHBORS. OFTEN PROGRAMS MUST
MIX TUITION PRIVATE FUNDING WAS
I THINK I SPENDING TO MEET
COMMUNITY NEEDS. ENOUGH MONEY.
A VIABLE. IN NINETEEN DEVASTATE
OUR CHILD CARE SYSTEM. AFTER
COUNTY ORIGINALLY TWO THIRDS OF
OUR PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
PROVIDERS CLOSED. MANY OF OUR
CURRENT ESSENTIAL WORKERS LOST
THEIR FULL THE CHILD CARE THE
REASONS VARIED THOSE DESIGNATED
NONESSENTIAL WE'RE NOT ALLOWED
TO BRING THEIR CHILDREN TO CARE
OVER LAID OFF AND HAD TO STOP
PAYINGFOR CARE. MANY PROGRAMS
HAD TO CLOSE THE LACK OF
ATTENDANCE MEANING LACK OF
INCOME SOME CLOSED BECAUSE THEY
WERE SCARED OR HAD PEOPLE OVER
SIXTY FIVE OR WITH PRE EXISTING
CONDITIONS LIVING IN THEIR HOME.
AS MUCH AS CHILD CARE. ARE
DEVOTED TO THE CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES THE CHILD CARE
WORKFORCE IS NOT REIMBURSED
ENOUGH TO RISK THEIR LIVES AND
THE LIVESAND THEIR FAMILIES.
ESPECIALLY WITH NO ACCESS TO
SANITIZING SUPPLIES GLOVES
WHITE. FACE COVERINGS ENHANCE
ENERGIZER. MANY OF OUR CLOSE
PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFULLY
OPERATING FOR DECADES AND I
WORRY THAT MANY WILL NOT
WEATHER THE FINANCIAL STORM.
AND BE ABLE TO RE OPEN. MY OWN
PROGRAM IS AN ALLEY ON A SCHOOL
CAMPUS. WHEN THE SCHOOLS CLOSED
WE HAD TO. AS WE HAVE NO ACCESS
TO OUR CLASSROOMS JANITORIAL
SERVICE. SCHOOL I'M NOT YES.
RECALL THE NINETEEN HAVE LONG
WAITING LISTS FOR T<c.cyan> CARE.</c>
MANY OF OUR CURRENTLY ENROLLED
SUBSIDIZE FAMILIES AS DOCTOR
ONLY WAS REFERRING TO ARE NOW
DESIGNATED AS ESSENTIAL.
THEY'VE ALWAYS BEEN ESSENTIAL.
EMERGENCY CHILDCARE VOUCHER
PROGRAM HAS BEEN A LIFELINE FOR
ESSENTIAL WORKERS AND FOR OUR
PROVIDERS SINCE THE EMERGENCY
CHILD CARE ABOUT YOUR PROGRAM
WE HAD A HAD A 25% INCREASE IN
THE NUMBER OF PROVIDERS THAT
WERE ABLE TO RE OPEN RANG US UP
TO FIFTY PERCENT. WE ALL
RESOURCE CENTER FOR ALL HE'S IN
CALIFORNIA WE'RE READY WITH THE
KNOWLEDGE OF CHILD CARE
VACANCIES AND IN LESS THAN
EIGHT. ON ME IT HUNDRED SIXTY
CHILDREN OF WORKERS. I IMAGINE
NEED AND- MANY OF THESE
FAMILIES THAT WE WORK JUST. THE
CURRENT INCOME GUIDELINES TO
QUALIFY FOR STATES I THINK I
SCARE SO IT REALLY MAKE A
DIFFERENCE HAVE INCOME
GUIDELINES WAIT. WELL SOME OF
THE CHILDREN OF SCHOOL AGE MANY
OF THE CHILDREN ARE BELOW THE
AGE OF FIVE. SUGGESTING THAT
THERE WAS A TWO MINUTE
HEALTHCARE FIRST THE WORK. JUST
A THE STATE INCOME. ECHO BUT
NINETEEN BROUGHT TO LIGHT. WE
ARE SO GRATEFUL TO THE EARLY
LEARNING CARE DIVISION
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE BECAUSE
THEIR GUIDANCE AND PROMISE AND
HOPE OF FINDING REALLY GOT US
THROUGH THIS VERY DIFFICULT
TIME. BUT LOOKING AHEAD RE
OPENING SLOWLY IS GOING TO BE A
CHALLENGE WE HAVE TO PLAN FOR
WHAT WE DON'T KNOW AND FOR WHAT
IS WITH NOT WAS NOT WITHIN OUR
CONTROL. I'LL COMMENT QUICKLY
ON THREE THINGS FIRST OF ALL WE
HAVE TO THINK ABOUT FACILITIES
SUPPLIES. WE WILL NEED FUNDING
TO MAKE OUR SPACES AVAILABLE TO
HAVE CHILDREN PHYSICALLY
DISTANT AS THE GOVERNOR TALKED
ABOUT IN HIS- UPDATE TODAY. WE
DON'T KNOW IF WE NEED MORE
CLASSROOMS FOR EARLY CHILDHOOD
SPACES AND WE DON'T KNOW IF THE
K. TWELVE WORLD WILL NEED OUR
SPACES SO THAT THEY CAN
PHYSICALLY DISTANT. WHAT WE
KNOW FOR SURE IS THAT WE WILL
NOT HAVE ENOUGH SPACES IF WE
DON'T FULLY ENGAGE IN SUPPORT
THE ENTIRE MIX DELIVERY AND THE
CHILD CARE SYSTEM. WE NEED ZIP
TIES AS THE LCD AND DOCTOR ONLY
REFER TO. BECAUSE THAT WILL
HELP SOME. PROVIDERS TO BE ABLE
TO OPEN. SECOND OF ALL I HAVE
TO POINT OUT IS A COUNTY OFFICE
OF EDUCATION. THE SCHOOL
READINESS STILL MATTERS. AND IT
SEEMS THE CONVERSATION ABOUT
HIGH QUALITY CARE. SCHOOL
READING THIS AND EARLY LEARNING
ARE NOT. DISCUSSED AS MUCH
CHILD CARE. I HAVE TO POINT OUT
A HIGH QUALITY CHILDCARE
INCLUDES EARLY LEARNING AND
FULL DAY EARLY LEARNING
INCLUDES CHILD CARE. WE HEARD
EXPERTS EARLIER TODAY TALKING.
TWELVE LEARNING ONCE BUT SCHOOL
READINESS IN LEARNING READINESS
FOR YOUNGEST CHILDREN MATTERS
JUST AS MUCH AS K. TWELVE
EDUCATION WE'RE AGAIN GRATEFUL
THE LCD THAT WE WERE ABLE TO BE
FOUND ITS REMAIN SERVING.
CHILDREN ACROSS OUR PROGRAMS.
ARE ZOOMING AND BLOOMING I
CANNOT TELL YOU THEY LOVE
HAVING THAT INTERACTION AND
ALSO WERE ABLE TO PROVIDE
SUPPORT TO OUR FAMILIES.
REFERRING TO FOOD BANKS AND
HELPING THEM DURING THIS VERY
DIFFICULT TIME IS MANY OF THEM
HAVE LOST INCOME. IN THE THIRD
YES I THINK ABOUT OUR FINANCES.
YOU KNOW THE CENTRAL WORKERS
WHEN THE CHILD CARE PAST JUNE
THIRTIETH. WE WORRY ABOUT THE
CHILDREN WHO WERE JUST SETTLING
INTO CARE AND BONDING IN
LEARNING WITH THEIR CARE
GIVERS. AND WE WORRY FOR
FAMILIES THIS IS THE ONLY CHILD
CARE IS KOBE NINETEEN IS NOT
GOING AWAY. WE WORRY ABOUT
THOSE FAMILIES WHO ARE JUST
OVER THE INCOME GUIDELINES IT
WILL NOT BE ELIGIBLE FOR
SUBSIDIZED CARE. WE ALSO NEED
CONTINUED FIRST THIS CALL
FLEXIBILITY FOR THOSE
CONTRACTORS WHO ARE ABLE TO
SHIP FINE. TUMOR CHILDCARE
VOUCHER. THOSE OF US WHO ARE
FULL DAY PROGRAMS NO WITH
PHYSICAL DISTANCE. I NEVER
FIRST TO WE CAN FULLY OR NOT.
AND STAFF WHICH COULD LEAD TO
LAYOFFS. WE HOPE THAT STATE
FUNDED CONTRACTORS TO HELP OUR
LIST FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
FISCAL YEAR AND HAVE OUR
PORTIONS MINTS. BASED ON
EXPENSES UP TO A MAXIMUM
REIMBURSABLE AMOUNTS RATHER
THAN ONLY ENROLLMENT AND
ATTENDANCE. A TEACHER OF A FOUR
YEAR OLD AND A TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN PROGRAM DOES NOT
NEED TO WORRY ABOUT HIS OR HER
JOB. A TEACHER OF A FOUR YEAR
OLD IN THE STATE RESULT PROGRAM
SHOULD HAVE THAT SAME PEACE OF
MIND. IT IS OUR HONOR TO ENROLL
IN HERE FOR CHILDREN OF THOSE
EMERGENCY SERVICES HEALTHCARE
GROCERY WORKERS CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE AND OTHERS%
DESIGNATED ASSISTANCE ALL. THE
FAMILY'S GRATITUDE HAS BEEN
OVERWHELMING AND THE VERB
MERGES THE VOUCHER PROGRAM IS
HELPING TO KEEP AT LEAST SOME.
OF OUR CLASSROOMS COUNTY CHILD
CARE WORKFORCE EMPLOYED. WE
KNOW THAT REVENUES ARE DOWN A
CHILD CARE IS VITAL TO THE
ECONOMIC. ENGINE OF THE STATE
PLEASE ENTER. THINK CHILDCARE
FOR ESSENTIAL WORK. CONTINUE
NOW THAT WE HAVE THE FUNDS TO
MAKE OUR SPACES SAFE AND
HEALTHY AND TO CARE FOR THE
WORK FORCE IT IS WORKING SO
HARD EVERY DAY HEARING FOR
THESE CHILDREN. WITH LOWERED
STUDENTS NEW REQUIREMENTS.
UNDER THE LEAST. CAN SEE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT CAN.
RENALDO SANDERS NEXT FROM THE
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS UNITED THE
PROJECT AS HE A UT TO UT W. AND
APPS ME. CAN YOU HEAR ME YES.
AWESOME GOOD AFTERNOON HI I AM
SO- PLEASED AND HAPPY AND CLOUT
EVEN WITH THIS AND THEY'RE LIKE
I'M HERE I TO SPEAK FOR FAMILY
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS I THANK
YOU AGAIN AND I'M JUST SO HAPPY.
OKAY MY NAME IS ONE OF THE
SANDERS AND I HAVE BEEN A
FAMILY CHILDCARE PROVIDER IN
THE CITY OF COMPTON OVER
THIRTY. TWO YEARS PLUS.
CURRENTLY MY DAYCARE- IS FILLED
WITH CHILDREN OF THIS SHOW
WORKERS RANGING FROM THE NURSES
AND GROCERY WORKERS TO BUS
DRIVERS AND TAX PREPARERS. AS A
RESULT AND THE NEED OF THE
CENTRAL WORKERS CHANGE. WE AND
I SAY WE BECAUSE MY SYSTEM IS
ALSO SO ACCOMMODATING ALSO
WE'RE WORKING TO ACCOMMODATE
OUR PARENTS AND OUR PROGRAM
AFTER ALL WE'RE IN THIS
TOGETHER. WE ARE MY DAY STARTED
BECAUSE WITH MY SYSTEM COMES
LATER USED TO BE AT FIVE I GET
UP AT FIVE IN BEGIN MY DAY BUT
NOW MY DAY BEGINS AT FOUR IN
ORDER TO ACCOMMODATE MY NURSES
WHO PICKED P EXTRA CALL WITH
YES. WHAT TO ACCOMMODATE MY
GROCERY WORKER PARENTS. TO
ACCOMMODATE OUR SENIORS ONLY
SHOPPING HOURS. BUT THAT'S NOT
THE ONLY THING THAT'S CHANGED
I'VE NOTICED AN ENTIRE NEW LOW
LEVEL STRESS ON MY ESSENTIAL
WORKERS HERE. STRESS THAT THEY
MIGHT BE INFECTED STRESS THAT
THEY MEAN BAKER CHILDREN ARE
THEIR OR THEIR BABIES THE
BABIES ARE FILLING STRESSES
ALSO. SO I WE CHANGED OUR DAILY
TEACHING OR LEARNING ACTIVITIES
TO WILL TEAMS- WHO SHOULD BE
MORE ENGAGING AND FUN USING
SOCIAL. SANDERS OUR AS I
MENTIONED ACTUALLY MADE BY WHAT
MY TEN YEAR OLD WE USED TO HAVE
FRIDAY AS OUR PHONE DAY NOW
EVERY DAY IS A FUN DAY. BUT
FRIDAY'S WAS FUND MIGHT BE
MARVELOUS. MARVELOUS MONDAY AND
SOMEONE AND SO ON. SO WOULD
CHANGE THEIR DAILY ACTIVITIES
TO INCLUDE THE SOCIAL
DISTANCING STANDARD ALSO WE'VE
INCLUDED COALBED NINETEEN-
SAFETY PRACTICES WE DON'T WANT
TO SCARE OUR CHILDREN BUT WE
WANT THEM SHOULD BE INVOLVED IN
TO KNOW THAT- THERE IS A VERY-
INSPECTION THAT'S GOING AROUND
OUT THERE WE WANT TO BE AS SAFE
AS POSSIBLE. ON WE'VE ALSO BEEN
ASKED TO MAINTAIN A MUCH
SOCIAL DISTANCE THE IN OUR DAY
CARE AS POSSIBLE. IT'S REALLY
SOMETIMES THEM POSSIBLE WITH
CHILDREN BUT WE HAVE DONE THE
BEST WE CAN BY CHANGING FROM
PHYSICAL HUGGING SO CROSSING
OUR ARMS AND FIVE OR FIVE.
DUCKS INCIDENT CIRCLE TIME
MOBILE PHONES ARE SITTING CLOSE
TO EACH OTHER ACROSS OUR HANDS
AND BONTA CRACKPOT. AS WELL
SOCIAL DISTANCING YES OUT.
HUNTSMAN SMOOCHES THROUGHOUT%
THE DAY ELBOW BOMBS ARE JUST HE
PLUS ALSO IT IS SOMETIMES HARD
BECAUSE I DON'T. IF THEY WANT
TO COME OVER SO THEY HAVE YOUR
LEGS. ARE WITH THE CORPORATE-
MANY THINGS THAT ARE WORKING
FOR US AND WE'RE JUST SO HAPPY
AND PROUD OF WHAT OUR BABIES
ARE AND FAMILIES ARE JUST VERY
VERY SPECIAL. OUR AND I FEEL
PROUD TO BE DOING MY PART. THAT
WE'RE DOING OUR PART TO HELP US
GET THROUGH THIS TOUGH CRISES.
BUT I WOULD BE LYING IF I WAS
TO SAY THAT I'M NOT SARED I'M
SCARED FOR MYSELF AS WELL AS MY
FAMILY THAT WE MIGHT BE IN.
THAT ANYTIME BUT I ALSO WANT
THE FAMILIES THAT ARE IN OUR
CARE APPEARANCE MY SOCIAL
ESSENTIAL WORKERS CHANNEL BUT
WHEN THEY LEAVE THEIR CHILDREN
WITH US IT'S STILL THERE ARE
STILL GOING TO. BE ABLE TO
RECEIVE THE SAME LOVE AND CARE.
THEY'RE HEALTHY MALES ALSO DALY
OF. AGE AND DEVELOPMENT
APPROPRIATE ACTIVITIES BY
FAMILY DAYCARE HOMES WE JUST
DON'T SIT THERE AND WATCH
TELEVISION WE ENGAGE OUR
CHILDREN. AND THIS IS NOT NAPA
WHICH MADE. FOR BUT- ROUTE TO
BE A PART OF THAT AND THAT. IS
OUR ARE. AS BUT WE ALWAYS SET.
I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW THE REASON
ACTS AND THAT THIS NEEDS TO
TAKE I BELIEVE THE STATE AS
WELL AS MY OUR CALL HURT SCHOOL
WHO ARE HEALTH PROVIDERS LIKE
ME CONTINUE TO KEEP OUR DOORS
OPEN. FIRST I'D LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE MY GRATITUDE TO THE
GOVERNOR FOR HIS FIFTY MILLION
INVESTMENT JOINT SHORE FAMILY
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS GET ACCESS
TO CLEANING SUPPLIES MPP. I
KEEPING OUR CHILD CARE'S
SABOTAGE IS CRUCIAL I WANT TO
STRESS. THE URGENCY AND GETTING
THOSE SUPPLIES AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE THANKS GETTING THEM.
AT OUR HOUSE OUR LOCAL STORES
ONLINE HAS BEEN IMPOSSIBLE. IN
MY DAY CARE CENTER TIGHTENING
IS CRUCIAL TO ME BEING ABLE TO
REMAIN OPEN. I KNOW PROVIDERS
AROUND THE STATE HAVE CLOSED
BECAUSE THEY HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE
TO REACH THE- DISINFECTANT
CLEANER SCORE MASS WORK WHAT.
SUDDENLY I WANT TO SHOW
APPRECIATION FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
FIFTY MILLION INVESTMENT IN
CHILDCARE. FOR ITS SENSUAL
WORKERS THIS IS A GREAT START
BUT IT ONLY OPENS UP TWENTY
THOUSAND SLOT. FOR TWO MONTHS
NOT NEARLY WHAT ARE ESSENTIAL
WORKERS ME THAT THEY CAN
CONTINUE ON WITH THEIR LIFE
SAVINGS OR- THIRD I CALL
CALIFORNIA TO ESTABLISH AND-
EIGHT WORKFORCE RETENTION AND
RECRUITMENT. PROGRAM ECP.
SECTORS WE KNOW FROM PAST
RECESSIONS BACK WHEN WE WHEN
CHILDCARE PROVIDER STRUGGLE AND
CLOSE THE DOORS DâN YEAH FIND
LACKS THE BLOW JOB HERE QUALITY
FLEXIBLE QUALITY JOB HERE. WE
CAN'T FIND THAT BE AND THAT'S
WHAT THEY NEED AS WE ARE-
SENTRY AND STATE GAINES
RECOVERY MOMENTOUS. BURKE I-
SUPPORTING CHILDCARE PROVIDERS
HEARING FOR THE CHILDREN OF
ESSENTIAL WORKERS NAME THE
PROVIDERS WILL BE ABLE TO. ALL
THE ACT IS THAT CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS WILL BE AVAILABLE TO
ALL. WHEN SCHOOLS RE OPENED THE
ECONOMY RECOVERS THERE IS HAVE
BEEN DOCUMENTED IT DOCUMENTED
THE OPERATING A CHILD HERE IN
THE COLD AT NINETEEN AND
FIREMEN WERE RAISES MORE THAN
20% ABOVE COST IN NORMAL NOT
PARENTS AND THEY MAKE. THE
TUITION. BOB TURNER DID PAYMENT
PROGRAMS WE'VE WE'VE HEARD FROM.
PARENTS AS WELL AS OTHER
PROVIDERS THAT ARE TARGETED
PAYMENT PROGRAMS. ARE GIVING
VOUCHERS AND TRYING TO REMOVE
VOUCHERS FROM PARENTS WHO ARE
HOME BUT- NOT ESSENTIAL WORKERS%
I HOPE THAT ISN'T TRUE IT
HASN'T I HAVEN'T HEARD A YEAR
PERSONALLY BUT OTHERS HALF.
THIS IS OPPOSITE FROM THE
GUIDANCE OF THE STATE HAS
PROVIDED IT UNDERMINES FAMILIES
NEEDED ACCESS TO CHILDCARE
SUPPORT NOW AND- ONCE SHOP
AROUND PLACED RESTRICTIONS ARE
LEFT IT. IT CREATES GREAT
UNCERTAINTY. FOR PROVIDERS IN
THE TERMS OF NOT BEING ABLE TO
CRY AND WHAT THEIR INCOME WILL
BE. THIS NEEDS TO BE CLARIFIED
THE MEDIA LAKE IN ORDER TO GIVE
US ALL PEACE OF MIND. FINALLY
WE MUST WE MUST WE MUST USE
THIS CRISIS AS AN OPPORTUNITY
TO START OVER AND DO THINGS
RIGHT WE MUST HOLD CORPORATIONS
ACCOUNTABLE. WHO ARE. FROM THE
PROVISIONS OF SHOP HERE IN
ORDER TO AVOID CUTS AND EXPAND
CHILDCARE FUNDING AS PART OF
THE EFFORT. TO REBUILD THE
ECONOMY POST PANDEMIC WE SHOULD
TAKE A LOOK AT CORPORATIONS
THAT BENEFIT FROM PUBLIC FROM
PUBLIC PROVISIONS OF JOB HERE
IN REQUIRED THEM TO JOIN US AND
SHOULDERING THE COST. I THANK
YOU SO VERY VERY MUCH. AND I
APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU SO
MUCH RUN ALL THE FOR THAT
PERSPECTIVE FOR. IT'S LIKE ON
THE GROUND AND- THANK YOU FOR
YOUR THIRTY TWO YEARS PLUS IN
SOUTH LA COUNTY. AND I THINK
THAT WAS HELPFUL FOR US TO GET
THEIR PERSPECTIVE FOR- PAY AT
FAMILY DAYCARE PROVIDER. THAT
CENTER BASE THAT LEADER WITH
THE- CHILDREN'S ALLIANCE THERE
WITH MR ALL NECK AS WELL AS
FROM THE STATE I HAVE A NUMBER
OF QUESTIONS I KNOW SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES TO AS WELL- I'LL
START OFF. AT THE OUTSET IT
AND- YOU KNOW IT IS THIS MR OWN
ACT HI I TALKED EARLIER ABOUT
THIS. HEADLINE IN- THIS IS NOT
THE ONLY ONE BUT- YOU KNOW
THERE'S FEAR THAT AFTER.
CORONAVIRUS OUR CENTERS IN
PROVIDERS WILL GO AWAY AND
NEVER COME BACK SO- THE
QUESTION WE HAVE TO ASK
OURSELVES IS NOT JUST HOW DO WE
GROW. EASY TO MAKE SURE IT'S
YOU KNOW UNIVERSALLY ACCESSIBLE
CALIFORNIA BUT HOW DO WE KEEP
THE ONES THAT THE PROGRAMS WE
HAVE. OPEN SO THE QUESTION IS
WHAT WILL IT TAKE TO RE OPEN
OUR CENTERS. AND INTO MORE
POORLY TODAY TO CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT. THEIR FINANCIAL
SOLVENCY. SIR THIS ISN'T- ANY
ISSUES THAT. ALL OF A SUDDEN
OCCURRED BECAUSE O THE
PANDEMIC WE'VE BEEN LOSING
CHILD CARE FAMILY CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS FOR THE LAST TEN
YEARS. BECAUSE THE COSTS. OF
PROVIDING THE CARE AND- HAVE
NOT KEPT UP. WITH WHAT THEY CAN
RECEIVE EITHER PAYMENTS FROM US
OR PAYMENTS FROM FAMILIES. AND
IT HAS BECOME MORE AND MORE
DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO MAKE ENDS
MEET- ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
OCCURS TO ME IS THAT WE PAY
BASED ON THE REGIONAL MARKET
RATE IN IN OUR ALTERNATIVE
PAYMENT PROGRAMS INTERCEPT
PROGRAMS. IN YET THAT ARE WE
THE MARKET IT IS A SURVEY
THAT'S DONE TWO YEARS PRIOR TO
WHATEVER IS GOING ON IN THIS
YEAR SO. YOU'RE ALWAYS BEHIND
THE EIGHT BALL AND THEN YOU GET
APPROVED IMAGE OF THE MARKET
YOU DON'T GET ALL OF. IT RATES.
IF I A IT HARD A LOT OF. THAT
ARE WILLING TO TAKE A- AND IN
PARTICULAR BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
GETTING REIMBURSED FOR THEIR
ACTUAL COSTS SO THERE WAS A
COST OF LIVING PIECE BUILT INTO
THE ARM ARE THAT WOULD BRING IT
UP TO CURRENT. AND BY THE WAY
IT DOESN'T BE KEPT UP AND WHAT
GETS BUDGET EVERY YEAR TO IT
SEEMS SOME YEARS WE GET IT
CURRENT. MEANING TWO YEARS LATE
FOR SOME YEARS IT'S EVEN MORE-
LATE THE NET THAT'S ONE ISSUE%
THE SECOND ISSUE IS THAT. THE
ONE OF PROVIDERS THAT WE HAVE
ARE GETTING OLDER IT'S- WE HAVE
QUITE A NUMBER OF IN THERE OVER
THE AGE OF SIXTY AND MANY OF
THEM OVER THE AGE OF SIXTY
FIVE. WILL BEEN DOING THIS FOR
A VERY LONG TIME. HAVE BEEN
TAKING IT VERY WELL FOR A VERY
LONG TIME BUT BETWEEN. I'M NOT
GETTING ENOUGH MONEY. AND THEIR
WEIGHT IS NOT BEING
COMMENSURATE WITH WHAT THEY CAN
DO OTHER WHAT OTHER WAYS. AND
MINIMUM WAGE REQUIREMENTS ARE.
AND ALL SORTS OF THINGS THAT
MAKE IT VERY DIFFICULT FOR THEM
TO MAKE A LIVING. ARE THERE
THERE'RE RETIRING AND THEIR NOT
COMING BACK AND SO I THINK ONE
OF THE THINGS WE HAVE TO LOOK
AT IS. THE WAY THE START THE
CREW A- YEAH. GREW OF CARE
PROVIDER MOSTLY SHOW ME CHAU.
WRITERS WHO WORK WITH THE
BABIES IN THE TODDLERS FOR THE
MOST PART. I'M TO COME ON
BOARD- WE RECEIVED A GRANT FROM
THE STEIN FOUNDATION THAT-
BRING THE PROCESS OF DOING
YOUTUBE CHANNEL. THE START TO
EDUCATE OUR- PEOPLE OUT IN THE
COMMUNITY THAT YOU CAN. YOU
KNOW TAKE CARE OF YOUR OWN
CHILDREN TAKE CARE OF OTHER
PEOPLE'S CHILDREN BECAUSE I
THINK THAT'S THE WAY A LOT OF
DAMAGE HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS
ORIGINALLY GOT INTO THE FIELD
WAS THEY THEY WERE LOOKING FOR
A WAY TO STAY HOME WITH THEIR
OWN KIDS. LOOKING FOR AN INCOME
STREAM SO THE TWO CHILDREN WERE
TO RENALDO WAS VERY AND THAT'S
THAT I THAT MUST BE HOW YOU GOT
INTO IT SO IT'S- OUR- YEAH. IN
YOU ADD. THE PANDEMIC A NEEDING
TO CLEAN AND THEN BEING AFRAID
AND ALL THOSE KINDS OF THINGS
AND WE NEED TO BUILD A MUCH
STRONGER SUPPORT SYSTEM. I AM
NEED TO RECOGNIZE THAT. OF
CHILD CARE WORKERS PROVIDERS
ARE ESSENTIAL WORKERS AND THEY
NEED TO BE RECOGNIZED BY THAT
AND THEY NEED TO BE COMPENSATED
ADEQUATELY TO BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE. RUN ALL THE DID YOU
WANT TO READ ALL THE DID YOU
WANT TO ADD ON TO THAT AS FAR
AS WHAT IT'S GONNA TAKE TO
KEEP. OUR FAMILY CHILD CARE
SETTINGS OR ARE CENTER BASED
PROGRAMS HOLD DURING ALL THIS.
YES I SINCE- APPRECIATE ARM
YOUR YOUR ADDRESS STATEMENTS
AND THEY WERE VERY ELDERLY NAY
WHAT'S YOUR I GUESS EDUCATION
ROCK OR EARLY CARE ON THE EARLY
FROM THE EASTERN EAST HAS BEEN
AT TIMES. IN ACCEPTABLE OR IT
MIGHT BE. OTHER PROGRAMS OUT I
THE GENERAL MENTIONED THE
ALLIANCE TWENTY YEARS AGO I
ALSO. HILL AND WENT TO MEETINGS
AND ROLL THE ALLIANCE THEY OUR
WORK WITH OUR LAKE ALL YEAH I
SENT A BURKE AND THEY SET UP
THE CHILD CARE TRAINING
INSTITUTE I WASN'T SURE I WAS A
TRAINER PROGRAM UNTIL THE
FUNDING. AVAILABLE SO WE TOP
PROVIDERS WE WENT OUT TO THEIR-
AFTER THEY ATTENDED SOMEBODY
TRAINING. WE ARE THE TIGERS
WILL GO TO THEIR HOMES AND HELP
THEM ALSO IT'S JUST A BETTER.
TO ME WE'RE GREAT IT WAS ON
EXPERIENCE YOU KNOW WE ALL CAN
LEARN FROM SITTING IN THE
CLASSROOM AND BOX OR VIDEO BUT
WHEN YOU GO OUT IN THE FIELD
THAT PERSONAL TOUCH AND I
BELIEVE THAT AND COMMUNITIES.
ARE THROUGH THE CENTERS YOU
KNOW IS NOT A COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
THE KING ARE SINCE YES WE DO
ALSO WE TELL OUR ARE PARENTS
COMING IN THE BAY CURE FOR YOUR
IS JUST OUT AND THIS IS HOW I
GOT STARTED MY MOTHER IN LAW
WORK MY FATHER IN LAW WORK
THERE'S NO ONE FOR MY SON AND I
WAS YOU KNOW YOUR MOTHER THIRTY
ONE YEARS OLD BUT I MIGHT. DO
SO I. CORPS THERE'S BEEN A MIX
EVER ME I WAS ABLE TO BE THERE
WITH MY SON ALSO CONTINUE MY
EDUCATION AND I'M STILL
LEARNING WHERE EVERY TRAINING
OR WHATEVER THAT'S GOING ON YOU
DO GET I'D LIKE THIS TO GET THE
WORD OUT AND HOW IMPORTANT
QUESTION IS AS FOR. EARLY IT
WAS WE WERE. THE CITY JUST SIT
ON BARNEY YOU KNOW SURROUND
WHAT BOND WHERE MOVEMENT NOW WE
ARE TEACHING WERE OUT THERE
WE'RE DOING HAVING WORKFORCE
JUST. ASK THAT WOULD TURN.
WOMEN BUT THE MEN WERE THEIR
OWN OFFICE AFTER NORTH BE THEIR
OWN THEIR OWN BIZ PEOPLE AND
THAT UP ECONOMIC GROWTH WHEN
THEM AS WELL AS OUR- SO GAS. I
THANK YOU ARE THANK YOU AND ALL
THE FOR DRESSING THAT AND I
HAVE A JOB TO FEW MORE
QUESTIONS BUT I WILL NOTE FOR
DOCTOR ALL NICK THAT DONE.
THANK YOU FOR TALKING ABOUT
THEIR RATE STRUCTURE AND THE
INADEQUATEAND OUT OF DATE- A
RATE STRUCTURE AS YOU KNOW
CENTER LEYVA AND I HAVE. JOINT
BILLS WORKING ON AS SEND WORD.
TALKING TO DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND OTHERS BECAUSE WE
REALIZE THIS IS NOT JUST A CO
IN NINETEEN ISSUE AS YOU STATED
BUT THIS WAS A LINGERING ISSUE.
THAT DEALS WITH THE OVERALL
FINANCIAL WHERE WITH ALL OF OUR
CENTER SO. WE HAVEN'T FORGOTTEN
THAT PIECE OF THANK YOU FOR
REMINDING US. MAYBE WE CAN NOW
GO TO THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND ASK YOU- A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS HERE. THE THERE
JESSICA. I AM HERE YEAH YEAH
OKAY ONE IS- ON IS HOW CAN WE
HOLD HARMLESS- VOUCHER
RECIPIENT PROVIDERS TO ENSURE
THAT THEY REMAIN OPEN WITH
FEWER FAMILIES- TO SERVE I
GUESS THAT'S TWO FOLD ONE IF
YOU'RE FAMILIES JUST BECAUSE
WHAT'S HAPPENING NOW THAT TOO
IT MAY BE A REALITY AT WHAT YOU
TALKED ABOUT EARLIER TODAY
GOVERNOR'S NEW DIRECT. WE'LL
BACK UP YOUR PEOPLE BEING IN A
IN A FACILITY SO HOW WOULD MAKE
SURE THAT THESE PROGRAMS ARE
FINANCIALLY VIABLE. BASED ON
THOSE TWO FACTORS. YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND THIS IS JUST GO HOME
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
SO- WE ARE LOOKING AT BOTH THE
CHANGING GUIDELINES AROUND-
SOCIAL DISTANCING- AS WELL AS-
A RECENT GUIDANCE- GIVEN BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND
SOCIAL SERVICES- AND WE'RE ALSO
LOOKING AT THAT IN CONJUNCTION
WITH YOUR GLOBAL RESOURCES THAT
WE HAVE. I'M AS I MENTIONED
BEFORE WE HAVE A FEDERAL KERR'S
ACTS FUNDS- AND WE'RE LOOKING
AT THIS NOW IN OUR IN OUR NEW
BUDGET PICTURE- WHERE WE ARE
DISSIPATING- LESS RESOURCES
OPPOSED TO ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
THE RECOGNIZING THAT THIS IS
THE KEY ELEMENT. I'M TO RE OPEN
OUR COMPANY. SO IN TERMS OF HOW
I THINK WE'RE STILL I'M
CONTEMPLATING YOU KNOW WHAT
WHAT THAT TYPE OF THE STRUCTURE
COULD LOOK LIKE- CERTAINLY OUR
EXISTING RIGHT STRUCTURE WAS
NOT- DEVELOPED WITH. SMALLER
RATIOS IN MIND- SO THAT
SOMETHING CERTAINLY THAT I
THINK WE WILL END UP HAVING-
I'M SOME PRETTY YEAH- LONG
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ABOUT- IN TERMS OF
ADDRESSING THOSE NEEDS. OKAY
AND MY NEXT QUESTION FOR YOU
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCES RELATE
TO THE DISCUSSION ON THE SHOW
WORKERS WE AT THERE IS A IS A
BIG NEED AS AS A DOCTOR ON LIKE
SAID WITH THE CURRENT. HEALTH
CARE WORKERS BUT THE REALITY IS
THERE ARE. ESSENTIAL WORKERS
THAT ARE BEYOND THAT TRUE
DEFINITION OF PUBLIC SAFETY AND
HEALTH CARE THEIR- PEOPLE TO
WORK IN RETAIL WHETHER THEY'RE
AT. GROCERY STORES ARE DOOR
DASHING OR OR AGRICULTURE.
FARMWORKERS YOU KNOW THERE'S A
LOT OF. THE CENTRAL WORKERS WHO
ARE LEFT OUT OF THIS AND SO- I
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU KNOW
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE YOU
YOU HAVE A JOB TO DO TO IT'S
ALL ABOUT DOLLARS AND CENTS AND
SO. WE HAVE THESE MONEY CAME IN
THROUGH THE ALLOCATION AND
THEY'RE BEING HELD BACK SO ARE
YOU ARE YOU ESSENTIALLY HOLDING
THE BACK. TO COVER THE HOLE
THAT YOU THINK THAT WE MAY FACE
THAT OUR CHILD CARE. BUDGET IN
CALIFORNIA OR IS IT POTENTIAL
TO USE THOSE MONIES NOW TO
SERVE THE SENSOR WORKERS THAT
NEED HELP TODAY. SO I WOULD
NOT- NECESSARILY AGREE WITH
THAT IDEA THAT WERE HOLDING
THESE FUNDS BACK- WE NEED TO-
PUT TOGETHER. SENATE SHOULD BE
SPENT AND WE NEED TO GET THE
WORD THE- INSURANCE ALREADY
THROUGH THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
AS WELL- I THINK THAT WE SEE
THAT POTENTIALLY HAPPENING TO
ME REVISION- BUT THERE ARE
OTHER AVENUES AS WELL SO IT'S
NOT JUST A SIMPLE AS- WE IN THE
FENCED ANNOUNCE OUR ALLOCATION
IN THE MONEY STARTS LOW- SO. NO
I DON'T I WOULDN'T SAY THAT
WERE HOLE IN THE MONEY BACK OR
SITTING ON THE MONEY- BUT THERE
ARE QUITE A FEW NEEDS IN THE
SYSTEM- AS AS OUR PANEL TODAY
DESCRIBED. AND PART OF THAT
THOSE KINDS IDENTIFYING WHICH
OF THOSE NEEDS WE CAN USE THEM
FOR OBVIOUSLY THREE UNDER FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IS NOT GOING TO
DO IT IN TERMS OF FOLKS ARE AT
WORK WHAT TO CAN. THIS AT. YOU
KNOW AT THE REQUIRE. AND IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE DEATH. GOING
WITH THE LEGISLATURE ON SHARKS
I CAN RESPECT ANSWERS SO LET ME
READ THAT NASA YOUR THAT YOU DO
IT AGAIN IN A DIFFERENT WAY-
ARE WE LOOKING TO USE THOSE
FEDERAL MONIES TO EXPAND
ACCESS- TO CONTINUE ACCESS
BECAUSE THAT'S ALWAYS THE
QUESTION WE HAVE. AFINITE
NUMBER OF SLOTS AND IN THIS
DIFFICULT SITUATION SOMETIMES
WILL BE FIGHTING JUST TO HOLD
ON TO WHAT WE GOT BUT IN THIS
CURRENT PANDEMIC COME
OVERSEEING fNTED
ON A DAILY BASIS WITH THE
GOVERNOR TALKED ABOUT TWO HOURS
AGO CHANGE THINGS IN A MONTH
FROM NOW. BUT ARE WE LOOKING AT
THOSE RESOURCES TO. HOLD ON TO
WHAT WE HAVE TO THE CURRENT
ACCESS OR TO EXPAND ACCESS
BECAUSE WE WERE HEARING FROM.
YOU KNOW MISTER GALLAGHER IS
NODDING HIS HEAD OVER HERE IN
AND THE AG WORLD AND WE HEARING
FROM PEOPLE WHO ARE IN THE
RETAIL WORLD AND- YOU KNOW LOW
WAGE WORKERS WHO HAVE THAT
CURRENT. CHILD CARE NEED TODAY
AND THERE IS SOME SO WORKERS
TODAY YOU CAN GO OUT ON THE
STREETS PEOPLE WHO ARE OUT
THERE YOU KNOW THESE ARE THOSE
WORKERS AND SO. WE JUST HOW DO
YOU RECONCILE THESE THESE TWO
THINGS. SO ONE THING THAT I
THINK IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE WHEN
ANSWERING THIS QUESTION IS THAT
THERE ARE. PARAMETERS AND
FEDERAL LAW- REGARDING THESE
CARES FUNDS AND HOW THEY'RE
USED. SO THE STATE. NOT USE
THESE FUNDS TO- SUPPLANT
EXISTING- APPROPRIATIONS AS
GENERAL FUND- OUR STATE OTHER
STATE FUNDS. FOR CHILDCARE- SO
THEY HAVE TO BE PROVIDED IN
ADDITION TO THAT. WE'RE TO
REIMBURSE THE STATE COSTS
ASSOCIATED CO THE NINETEEN THAT
WERE- IN CURRENT. AFTER THAT
HE- THE STATE OF EMERGENCY WAS
ANNOUNCED. SO IN TERMS OF WHAT
THEY'RE NOT WE SEE THESE AS
LIKE A BLACK FILL FOR EXISTING
STATE FUNDS. ALLOWABLE AND
PURSUANT TO THE FEDERAL LOST
SO- THIS WOULD BE IN ADDITION
TO THAT AND AT MOST AGAIN. I'M
BE REIMBURSED STATE. ALLOCATE
FOR CLEANING. OKAY I THAT
THAT'S A THINK SO IF. YEAH SO
THAT. BASICALLY SAYS WE'RE
LOOKINGTO EXPAND. NOT SUPPLANT
WHICH WILL BE CURRENTLY AB I
THINK THAT'S WHAT WAS WITH THE
PREFERRED- PAT THIS FOR
CALIFORNIA. AND LAST QUESTION
FOR YOU JESSICA WE TALKED ABOUT
THIS EARLIER WITH THE- WITH THE
K. TWELVE COMMUNITY ON THAT THE
STOCKPILE THE PP STOCKPILE IN
THIS MASSIVE ORDER THAT WE'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT THE BILLION
DOLLAR ORDER THAT. THAT WAS
ANNOUNCED THAT IT'S GOING TO
COME TO FRUITION SOON I KNOW WE
ALLOCATE MONEY ALREADY FOR THIS
BUT- HOW WILL THESE PROGRAMS
PROVIDERS BE ABLE TO ACCESS
THIS PP. ON ON A WELL THEY HAVE
TO USE DIP INTO THEIR OWN
RESOURCES EITHER THAT THEY HAVE
IN THE CURRENT BUDGET OR THAT'S
BEEN ALLOCATED THROUGH THIS.
THESE LAST YOU KNOW A FEW
MONTHS OR WILL JUST GET IN LINE
AND MAKE IT MAKE AND- MAKE A
REQUEST FOR THAT
VERY MUCH FOR THAT QUESTION AND
I DID FOLLOW UP ON YOUR
PREVIOUS QUESTION WITH MY
CONTACTS AND YES- AND- SO I
HAVE AN ANSWER ON THE ON THE
SCHOOLS QUESTION AS WHILE. I'M
SO THAT AS- CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS JUST LIKE AS AT ONLY
A PROVIDER ELLIE EIGHTY. ELLIE
IS THEY CAN WORK WITH THE
THROUGH THE EXISTING CITY AND
COUNTY- REGIONAL EMERGENCY
RESPONSE TEAMS THAT ARE IN
THOSE AREAS TO ACCESS PP IF
THEY CANNOT OTHERWISE GET IT
THROUGH AN INDEPENDENT MEANS-
AND- I CONTACTED- YES DID
CONFIRM FOR ME THAT GENERALLY
SPEAKING WHEN THOSE THOSE
REQUESTS COME THROUGH IN THE-
BY THE- THEY DON'T. I READ THAT
I DID. CHARGE HOWEVER IT DOES
NEED TO GO THROUGH THAT
REGIONAL EMERGENCY AS PROCESS-
AND I DO KNOW THAT- THAT
THROUGH SOME SOME- SOME FOLKS
ARE WORKING OVER DEPARTMENT
SOCIAL SERVICES THAT THERE ARE
A COUPLE OF COUNTIES WORK
WORKING WITH CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS TO ACCESS- NECESSARY
SUPPLIES BOTH PP SANITIZING
SUPPLIES. WELL AS- SO THAT'S IN
IN SOME MONEY THAT SOUNDS LIKE
THAT HAS ALREADY BEEN HALF.
OKAY THANK YOU FINALLY I HAVE
TWO QUICK QUESTIONS FOR CD. THE
FIRST IS RELATED TO OUR ACES
PROGRAMMER AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS IN CALIFORNIA. AND I
UNDERSTAND THERE'S SOME
GUIDANCE OR DIRECTION COMING
OUT. FOR THAT RELATED TO OUR
SUMMER ACES PROGRAMS AND
GRANTED A LOT OF THIS DEPENDS
ON THE THIS STATE- MORTAR BUT
ASSUMING THAT WE HAVE SOME
FLEXIBILITY- HOW ARE WE LOOKING
WITH OUR ACES- PROGRAM
CALIFORNIAN GUIDANCE FOR
PROVIDERS. USE THAT MUCH FOR
THAT QUESTION AS CHAIR. THIS IS
THEIR NUMBER MARKET WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION SO WE ACTUALLY
RELEASED AND GUIDANCE ON MONDAY
THAT DIRECTED ALL OF OUR GREEN
TEAS RACES IN TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY. THAT THEY WOULD BE
GETTING EXTENDED GRANT AWARDS
SO INSTEAD OF THE GRANT AWARD
ANY NINETEEN THIRTY AT THAT
WILL BE EXTENDED THROUGH
DECEMBER. ALLOWS THEM TO YOU
BUT A BAD AND GO DEEPER AND
THEIR SUMMER MONTHS SO THAT
THEY REALLY CAN BE PART OF THAT
SOLUTION. IN ADDRESSING THE
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT AROUND
LEARNING AROUND CARE THAT ARE
NEEDED AT THIS TIME. OKAY THANK
YOU AND THEN MY FINAL QUESTION
FOR CD IS-RELATED TO. PARENTS
WHO ARE. WHO ARE ELIGIBLE. ONLY
GO BACK TO THE ACES REAL QUICK
I'M SORRY SERRA- CAN YOU
CLARIFY ABOUT THE ASUS PROGRAM
AND THE RATES WILL THEY GET
THAT BETTER RATE THE HIGHER
RATE. UNFORTUNATELY I'M NOT
SURE ABOUT THE RATE HE SAID
THAT I'LL HAVE TO DROP IN AND
SEE AND GET BACK TO YOU ARE NOT
PLAN. OKAY NEXT BUT GOING BACK
TO OUR CD CHILD CARE PROGRAMS.
AND WE'RE HEARING FROM
PROVIDERS ACROSS THE STATE THAT
PARENTS ARE BEING CALLED AND
ASKED TO GIVE UP THEIR CARE
BECAUSE THERE ARE NOT WORKING
OR THEY ARE SHELTERING IN
PLACE- CAN CLARIFY. S. R.
SOLDIERING IN PLACING FAMILIES.
TO SEE TO CLARIFY THEY HAVE NOT
LOST THEIR ELIGIBILITY. I THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT QUESTION
WE WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR TO
EVERYONE OUT THERE ARE FAMILIES
THAT CAME IN BEFORE COULD
NINETEEN. ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
TWELVE MY- AND SO IN NOT IF
THAT FAMILY IS NOT AN ESSENTIAL
WORKER AND THEY HAVE DECIDED TO
SHELTER PLACE AND FOLLOW THAT.
THEY ARE STILL BEING HELD WITH
THAT AND THEIR PROVIDER WHEN.
HE A FAMILY MEMBER FAMILY
CHILDCARE OR CENTER BASED.
EITHER HE SAID GEN FOUR THROUGH
OUR DIRECT CONTRACT. ARE
CONTINUING TO RECEIVE THAT
PAIN. THAT WAS VERY IMPORTANT
TO US ON THE- TOP MAN ALLEGE
ABOUT EIGHT. A LOT OF FAMILIES.
AND OUR CELL PLAYS AND SUMMER
COMING BACK TO THE PROGRAM NOW.
ON PROGRAMS AT THE NOT BASED ON
THE FACT THAT THEY ARE AN
ESSENTIAL WORKERS. AND IT IS
NOT FOR US AND ASK THEM IF A
FAMILY HAS CONTINUED TO GO TO
CARE WE ARE PRESUMING THAT THEY
ARE ESSENTIAL WORKERS. BECAUSE
THEY NEEDED TO CONTINUE HAVING
THEIR CHILDREN THEIR CHILD CARE
SITUATION AND IF THEY'RE
RETURNING TO CARE RIGHT NOW. IN
SORT OF THING WE ARE AS- AS-
HAS FOR THE ABILITY THERE ARE
NEED TO WORKING A TO EARLY
LEARN. CARE PROGRAM SO THAT
THAT FAMILY CAN WORK AS AN
ESSENTIAL WORKER. SO BOTH PARTS
OF OUR THERE SHOULD BE COVERED
WITH THIS PAIN STILL. FAMILIES
BEANS OR AT. ALL FAMILIES
SHOULD BE OUR STILL JUST TO
MAKE SURE THAT THERE ARE TO
CHECK AGAIN BUT NOT TOO OUT TO
REDUCE AND NOT TO SPEND IF
THEY'VE LOST A JOB AND
THEREFORE SHOULD BE GIVING UP
THEIR CARE THERE ARE MULTIPLE
FOR THAT AND THEIR ARE EXPAND
THEIR WORK BUT THIS HOURS DOWN
THERE TWELVE. ELIGIBILITY OKAY
THAT QUESTION ABOUT GO ON
MEMBERS AT THAT FOR NOW I WANT
TO CALL ON ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE
MON WHO HAS SOME QUESTIONS FOR
HER AS A MEMBER THE COMMITTEE
BUT IN ADDITION AS WE KNOW IS
THE VICE CHAIR BECAUSE WILL
POCKETS AND THEY HAVE BEEN
ENGAGED MINISTRATION ON THESE
AS A CHILD CARE SHE SOME. THANK
YOU CHAIR AND THE BEING I'M ND
AS AS THE CHAIR SAID FOR THE
OVER TWO DECADES THE
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS HAS
PRIORITIZE CHILD CARE I'M IN IN
THOSE TWO DECADES WE EVERY YEAR
RECOGNIZE AT. THE CHILD CARE WE
DO HAVE IS NOT ENOUGH
SUFFICIENT- IT TO MEET THE
DEMANDS OF THE OF CALIFORNIA
AND WHAT'S HAPPENED WITH THIS
SITUATION IS THAT IT'S JUST
EXASPERATED THAT THE PROBLEM-
TO A GREATER LEVEL AND THERE
ARE SEVERAL ISSUES THE THING
CAME UP THAT HAVE COME UP APRIL
TENTH THE LETTER IN WOMEN'S
AKIS. EACH LETTER TO THE
GOVERNOR- THEY WANT TO BE THERE
IT'S A- PARTIES. THE BOB CAN
AKAKA. AN AND WE DID
CHARACTERIZE AND I DO RESPECT
THE COMMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
MADE AT A- HERE TODAY BUT WE
DID OUR TO RISE- THAT WE
WANTED- THE FUND THE FEDERAL
FUNDS RELEASED- FAIR ENOUGH IF
THERE'S A DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE
POWER WORDING THAT- IT. IS
SOMETHING THAT WE STILL- CARE
ABOUT WE'D LIKE TO KNOW WHAT
THE TIME LINE IS TO DETERMINE
HOW AND WHEN. THE IS MY BE
GETTING TO. THE PROVIDE CELLS-
ADDITIONALLY WE ASKED FOR A
THIRTY DAY. THE HOW A WHOLE A
THIRTY DAY HOME HOLD HARMLESS-
FOR CLOSE PROVIDERS-
PARTICULARLY OUT OF FEAR THAT
WE ARE GOING TO LOSE- SOME OF
THE PROVIDERS- THAT WE HAVE
NOW- AND EVEN COMING UP FOR ALL
THE THINGS THAT HAVE BEEN SET
THUS FAR- A WE MAY. ALSO SEE
THAT WOULD YOU KNOW A YEAR OR
TWO DOWN THE LINE WE MAY NOT BE
ABLE TO GET- WILL BE EVEN MORE
SHORT. OF THE NEED THAT WE HAVE
IN THE STATE AND IT'LL BE MORE
DIFFICULT FOR US TO FIND
PROVIDERS- AND IN THE THIRD DAY
THAT WE ASKED FOR WAS HAZARD
PAY FOR A CHILD. CARE WORKERS
AND SO I JUST WANT TO I WANT
THAT LETTER AND TO GO INTO THE
RECORD BECAUSE THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT THE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS- HAS BEEN. A CHAMPION
MEAN FOR MANY DECADES. BUT ALSO
RECOGNIZING. EACH AND EVERY
YEAR WE'VE NEVER BEEN ABLE AS A
STATE TO MEET THE DEMAND- FOR
CHILD CARE. NOW WE DID IT AT.
YOU KNOW PRIOR TO THIS
PANDEMIC- THE SYSTEM WAS
ALREADY STRUGGLING AS I SAID TO
MEET THE NEEDS- AND NOW. WE ARE
REALLY LOOKING AND FOCUSING AT
OUR ESSENTIAL WORKERS AND IT
WAS A REALLY IMPORTANT I THINK
TO HAVE THE PERSPECTIVE- NALDO-
YOU KNOW JUST TALKING ABOUT HOW
YOU HAVE TO CHANGE YOUR HOURS
BECAUSE NOW THE WORKERS. IN THE
IN. NEED MORE FLEXIBLE THAN
EVER BE THE DEMAND IS HIGH FREE
CENTRAL WORKERS. SO I THINK
JUST HEARING THAT PERSPECTIVE
HOW IT'S IMPACTING. A CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS IS REALLY
IMPORTANT BUT WHAT WE DO AS A
STATE- RIGHT NOW TO EVEN MEET.
EVEN MEET THE NEEDS OF A SET
WORKERS I'M IT SEEMS LIKE A
VERY DIFFICULT THING TO DO AT
THIS PARTICULAR TIME KNOWING
THAT WE CAN'T MEET THE NEEDS OF
THE WHOLE STATE BUT JUST
LOOKING AT SMALL SECTOR- WHAT
IS LEFT FOR US. TO CONSIDER AND
TO DO- A IN TERMS OF THAT
MEETING THAT DEMAND FOR EAST
CENTRAL WORKERS. WHOEVER WANTS
TO TAKE A STAB AT THAT. THANK
YOU ARE SENATOR LEMOND AND YOU
KNOW WE LOVE YOU SO MUCH AND
YOU SPONSORED ARE BILL EIGHTY
THREE SEVENTY EIGHT HE'S ALWAYS
BEEN THERE YOU JUST. SUCH A
BLESSING BUT IF THERE ARE GOOD
CAN I GIVE AN XAMPLE- I DON'T
WANT TO SAY THE NAME OF MY
RESEARCH AND WE ARE ALL. BUT
THEY SENT OUT A QUESTIONNAIRE
WHAT IS SHOW. MATERIALS ARE
THEY WERE CALLED PPVS. YEAH WE
NEED AND SO BECAUSE OF GROW THE
WONDERFUL HELP WITH MY
NEIGHBORS MY FAMILIES IN OUR
PROGRAM. THEY SUPPLIED US WITH
SO MANY THINGS. THE ONLY THINGS
THAT WE DIDN'T HAVE. ACCESS TO
AT THAT TIME OR MASS. AND THEY
ALSO IN THE QUESTIONNAIRE ASKED
HOW MAYBE HOW MANY STAFF. DO SO
IS MY ASSISTANT- MYSELF SO
THAT'S WHAT I PUT DOWN ONLY
ASPER MASS SO THEN THEY CALLED
OKAY IT'S DONE PRETTY GOOD TO
GET YOUR SUPPLIES WE DRIVE
CLEAR TO COMBAT. YOU ARE NOT
GOING TO SAY WHERE MY RESOURCE
AND REFERRAL AGENCIES AND THEY
GAVE US YOU. ASKED HE W. WHAT.
NOT RIGHT MY PROBLEM SO MAYBE
IF I FLOOD BUTLATER THEY
CALLED THEM BOUGHT OUT FOR ONLY
BECAUSE I BELIEVE THIS ON MY
ARTICLE USE WAIT. I'M SORRY BUT
I FOR ALL PROVIDE IF YOU HAVE
THINGS YOU KNOW. TO THE- AS A
LOAF OF BREAD GIVEN UP OF
WRITING ABOUT NOT G. THE FISH
MADE FISH IN THE YOU KNOW WHAT
WELL AND ALL THE COOL PEOPLE WE.
WE JUST WOULD LIKE WHAT WHAT
YOU CAN TO OFFER IF IT A NOT
LEAST LET US KNOW. ONE OF THE
PROVIDERS IN MY GET OUT TO VOTE
GROUP HAD TRIED TO GET SUPPLIES
ALSO AND SHE WAS LIKE THEY
BALK. AT IT WILL TOGETHER SO.
WHAT DO YOU NEED TO THE
DISINFECTANTS BLEACHED ONESELF
OR IT SOUNDS LIKE CALL HER THEY
DIDN'T HAVE BELIEVES THEY
DIDN'T HAVE. THANKS THEY DIDN'T
ARE THE DISINFECTANT WIPES SO I
SAID IS THERE ANYTHING ELSE USE
SHE WAS CRYING THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR CARING AND THINKING
ABOUT ME MY SISTER BUT SHE SAID
SHE HAD CHALLENGES. THAT FOR
HER CHILDREN BUT YOU KNOW SO
WE'RE HELPING OTHER BUT WE
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO THESE
THINGS WE ALSO DON'T MIND
LICENSE AT CAUGHT. TRYING TO
GET. IT DIDN'T MATTER THEY
STILL PUT US ON THE LINE FOR
TWO A HALF HOURS THEN WE DIDN'T
UNABLE TO LEAVE THE GOOD.
BECAUSE I'M MORE. THANK YOU
PROVIDING THAT PERSON AND YOU
KNOW WE'RE NOT YOU'RE NOT THE
ONLY ONE THAT HAS A THINK
SPOKEN TO LEGISLATORS ABOUT.
THE THIS SERIOUS DIFFICULTY IN
AND FINDING SUPPLIES FOR
CHILDCARE WORKERS AND I'M
WONDERING IF ANYONE FROM THE
STATE CAN I RESPOND TO THAT AND
LET US KNOW WHAT IT WHAT IS THE
STATE DOING TO. I MEAN THERE
WAS MY INITIAL QUESTION OF WHAT
ARE WE DOING TO MEET THE DEMAND
FOR US TO WORKERS BUT THEN
THERE'S THE QUESTION NOW WHAT
ARE WE DOING TO GET BASIC
HEALTH. AND SAFETY SUPPLIES TO
HEALTH CARE. THAT VERY HIGH
PRICE IS NOT BEING ABLE TO
BENEFIT FROM BULK PURCHASING-
AND I'M WONDERING IF THE STATE
CAN PLEASE RESPOND TO THAT. AND
THIS IS JUST GOT HOME FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SO- YOU
KNOW WE IS SP I'M SORRY. AND WE
PROVIDED AT THROUGH. A SECTION
THIRTY SIX LADDERS FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO HELP. A
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS PURCHASE
THE SUPPLIES THEY NEED IN ORDER
TO CLEAN SANITIZED- AND PROVIDE
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT FOR
THEMSELVES- HOWEVER WE
RECOGNIZE THAT- NOT ALL.
PROVIDERS HAD ACCESS YOU KNOW
YOU YOU CAN HAVE THE DOLLARS
BUT NOT THIS DALY THE ACCESS
TO- SUPPLIES THEMSELVES. AS I
NOTED THERE ARE OPPORTUNITIES
TO WORK WITH ME IN CITY. I AM.
AGENCY THAT REPRESENTS- THEIR
REGIONS I'M WITH IN THAT
STATEWIDE EMERGENCY STRUCTURE
TO ACCESS ADDITIONAL SUPPLIES.
BUT ALSO- YOU KNOW LOOKING AT
DIFFERENT OPTIONS BE ABOUT PAUL
I'M WORKING WITH OUR OTHER
PARTNER. BUT THIS IS A FULL
TUITION- YOU KNOW IT'S- I'M IT
IS IT IS SOMETHING THAT WE'RE
CONTINUING TO WORK ON- BUT IT'S
REALLY HELPFUL TO HEAL HERE
WITH THE EXPERIENCES HAVE BEEN
ON THE ON THE GROUND LEVEL. I
QUESTION AND REMEMBER THE MAN
THIS IS THE KIND OF A MARKET
THAT CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT AND
DAD. SO WHERE THE ONES WHO ARE
ADDRESSING THE FIFTEEN AND THAT
YOU ALL OF THE- STATE AND-
INSURE THAT CLEANING SUPPLIES
GET OUT TO YOU ARE TO
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS. SO DOES
FUNDS RIGHT OUR CITY THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE AND WE
HAVE A LOT THAT SHOULD BE GOING
OUT TO OUR SUMMER FOR LIKE. TWO
DAYS. NOT THERE I LIKE HE'S IN.
SAID THOSE. WILL GO TO EACH OF
OUR ARE NOT. WORK WITH. OUR
LEARNING. CARE PROVIDERS.
COMMUNITIES BUT AS- JUST AS BAD
DEPARTMENT OF ONE OF THE ISSUE
IS AN ACCESS SO WE KNOW RIGHT
ACROSS THIS IS A VARIETY OF
ACCESS ISSUES NOT JUST FOR
EARLY LEARNING CARE BUT ALSO
STILL FOR HEALTH CARE AND
RATHER SECTORS SO I THINK. THE
SHORTER IT'S THERE'S A
COMPETING DEMANDS BUT WE DO
KNOW AND WE'VE SEEN PICTURES
FROM SOME OF OUR AROUND IN SAN
DIEGO AND OTHER PLACES WHERE
REALLY ARE AS HE SAID HE COUNTY
WORKING WITH OUR AND OURS FIRST
FIVE COUNTY COMMISSION AND-
EIGHT PEOPLE. SORT OF THAT
WHOLE WORLD GATHERED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEIR PURCHASING
THINGS AND GETTING THEM TO THE
PROVIDER SO WE NEVER NEVER FAST
ENOUGH WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE
OTHER ISSUES THAT WOULD GET IN
THE WAY ITHINK THAT YOU KNOW
SOME RESORT WILL BE KIND. OUT
OF WORK OUT FOR. LOCAL IT CAN
SEE. CONTRACTS OR AN ALLEY A-
OKAY THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
O'DONNELL WANTED TO DO THAT ADD
ON TO THIS ISSUE AND THEN GO
BACK TO MY MEMORY LOSS YES THE
THANK YOU JUST WANT TO JUMP
HERE APPRECIATE THAT A SUMMER
LEAGUE AMONG- I'M MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THERE IS THERE
ARE ESTABLISHED PROTOCOLS WITH
REGARD TO HOW- ELLIE A- AND I
ASSUME CHILD PROVIDERS WILL GET.
THE P. HE COMES OUT OF THE
STATE. THE STATE'S. SENATE TO
THE COUNTY- THEY COUNTY HEALTH
OFFICER HER THERE THAT THE
COUNTY. THE COUNTY- HEALTH
DEPARTMENT AND THEN IT IS DOLED
OUT. BY I ASSUME THE COUNTY
HEALTH OFFICER IN AGAIN THE
COUNTY HEALTH DEPARTMENT AND AM
I CORRECT ON THAT THERE SHOULD
BE NO OTHER PATH. OTHER THAN
SEEING OF A PRIVATE PROVIDER
THAT ONE WOULD GO TO. GET P. P.
M. I. N. CORRECTION I BECAUSE
THAT'S MY UNDERSTANDING IS JUST
IS THE SYSTEM IS. IS RATHER
ESTABLISH THE PROTOCOLS ARE
RATHER ESTABLISH AND THAT IS
THE PATH. OF HOW WE GET P. P.
P. P. V. E. OUT. TO THOSE WHO
NEED IT COULD COULD SOMEONE
pRIGHT ON ALL THIS IS JUST
CONSIDER PART OF FINANCE YES
THERE IS THAT PROCESS- AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL THAT AND ALLOWS FOR
THE STATE SRPRISED DISTRICT. I
AGREE I JUST GET A LITTLE
CONFUSING PEOPLE SAY WELL. YEAH
THIS MIGHT HAPPEN AND THEN.
WE'RE INTO A LETTER AND THINGS
LIKE THAT THAT'S I'M NOT SAYING
THAT'S NOT NECESSARY AS MUCH AS
THERE'S A PATH IT SHOULD WE ONE
SHOULD NOT DEVIATE FROM THAT
PATH CAN'T GET IT FROM A
PRIVATE CONTRACTOR. THEY NEED
ITIS ESSENTIAL THEY CALL THEIR
COUNTY HEALTH OFFICER THERE
COUNTY HA HEALTH OFFICER THEN
GETS IT TO THEM THAT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING. OF THE
ESTABLISHED PROTOCOL RIGHT NOW
AND THAT PEOPLE SHOULD BE
FOLLOWING AND THEN NOT
DEVIATING FROM THAT. BECAUSE
YOU'RE PROBABLY JUST GONNA SPIN
YOUR WHEELS OF AND HEARD FROM.
OUR CLASSIFIED FOLKS. THAT ARE
ON THE LINE RIGHT NOW TEACHERS
IN GENERAL ARE AT SCHOOL TIGHTS
BUT THE CLOCK BY TRUCKS ARE
PROVIDING MEALS THAT THEY NEED
SOME OF THE EQUIPMENT- TODAY
APPARENTLY. THE OWNER OF THE-
HE GOVERNOR ORDER FROM SOMEONE
ARRIVED IN CALIFORNIA SO. I'M
EXPECTING THAT THEY SHOULDN'T
BE A HUGE PROBLEM GIVEN THAT WE
HAVE PROTOCOLS- TO ADDRESS
LOGISTICS AND GIVEN THAT WE
JUST HAVE MORE OF THEM LANDED
HERE TODAY WITH THAT THANK YOU.
IF I THE- BREAK IN FOR A SECOND
ON ON THE WHOLE ISSUE PPVS AND
HOW THEY'RE COMING TO US. UP
UNTIL THIS POINT THERE HASN'T
BEEN A LOT OF. MASKS OR
CLEANING SUPPLIES OR ANYTHING
ELSE OUT THERE TO RECEIVE AND
WE'VE SORT OF GONE TO ARE
INDIVIDUALLY AND ASKED WHOEVER
WE CAN FOR DONATIONS TO BUY
THEIR OWN SUPPLIES TO GIVE AWAY
WE'VE GOTTEN SOME DONATIONS
FROM VARIOUS PLACES THIS BUT
THERE HAVEN'T BEEN A LOT OF
MASKS AVAILABLE ANYWHERE. UP
UNTIL NOW SO FULLY WITH WITH-
HEARING FROM THE STATE THAT
THERE'S GOING TO BE IN ANY
AVAILABLE- WILL BE ABLE TO USE
THOSE KIND OF PROTOCOLS BUT UP
UNTIL NOW IT'S KIND OF THE WILD
WILD WEST. THANK YOU MISTER
CHICKEN I SAYS. YES HE DID DID
YOU GO TO YOUR COUNTY HEALTH
DEPARTMENT YOUR COUNTY HEALTH
OFFICER IN ASKING FOR VP. WE'D
WE'D GET WELL WE DIDN'T GO TO
THEM WE ACTUALLY HAD TO COUNTY
OFFICES AND COME TO US AND SAY-
WE'VE- GOT A COMMISSION SOME
OF. WHAT IS IT. AB FIVE BYE
BABY WHO WHO. BILLS A LOT OF
THESE- EQUIPMENT AND GIVE AWAY
A LOT OF DIAPERS AND- YOU KNOW
ONCE. BASICALLY DISTRIBUTED OUT
TO THE ON ARTS FOR US TO
DISTRIBUTE SO- IT WAS A
DONATION FROM BETTER- I BABY TO
THE COUNTY TO US BUT- WE DID
NOT GO THROUGH THE- PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICERS IN OUR COUNTY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DOWN THIS IS
SERRA NOVEL MARKET WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION I WANT TO CLARIFY A
PART OF IT IS WELL IT'S BEYOND-
OR MAYBE LESS AND THE P. P. AND
ADDS BASIC FACE COVERINGS WE'VE
ALSO HAD EARLY LEARNING CARE
PROVIDERS NOT BE ABLE TO GET
DIAPERS. OR FOR ANY LACK AT BB
WHITE SUGGESTS BASIC SUPPLIES
THAT YOU WOULD NEED WHEN YOU'RE
CARRYING FOR YOUNG CHILDREN HAS
BEEN PART OF WHAT THEY NEEDED.
STATE HEALTH AND SAFETY SO JUST
BEING ABLE TO USE SOME BLEACH.
OR OTHER CLEANING PRODUCTS TO
WAIT THINGS DOWN. SO THE PP
EASIER RIGHT ARE VERY MUCH PART
OF THE STATE SUPPLY CHAIN. AND
THEN THERE'S OTHER RESOURCE
SAYS THAT WE'VE NEEDED TO
SUPPORT OUR EARLIER MEANING
CARE PROGRAMS AND SO. WE'RE
TALKING MORE THAT AND GET THAT
AND YES WE ARE PUTTING PEOPLE
IN TOUCH WITH THEIR KIDS HE
THROUGH THAT. PART OF THE PP
SUPPLY CHAIN. AT IN TRYING TO
ADDRESS OTHER NEEDS TO MAKE
SURE CHILDREN ARE AND HEALTH.
AND SAFETY IMPAIRMENTS. THANK
YOU. SO AS A FOLLOW UP TO THAT
THEN YOU KNOW IT'S CLEAR THAT
OUT OF NECESSITY- NOT EVERYONE
HAS FOLLOWED THE SAME A PROCESS
BUT WHEN DO WE EXPECT IF WE
HAVE A SHIPMENT OF MASS COMING
IN TO THE STATE'S THAT WAS
ORDERED BY THE GOVERNOR WHEN DO
WE EXPECT AT LEAST FOR CHILD
CARE WORKERS THAT THEY WILL SEE
A SURPRISE DO WITH THE TIME.
LINE FOR THAT. THIS IS JUST
GONE TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND I DON'T HAVE THAT
INFORMATION- I CAN REACH OUT
THOUGH TO- MY COUNTERPARTS AND
REYES. YES AND- TO WRITE
INFORMATION I CAN GET FOR YOU.
THANK YOU THAT WOULD BE GREAT.
AND YOU KNOW FINALLY AT
YESTERDAY THERE WAS A CALL THAT
THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS HAD WITH OUR
GOVERNOR. AND WE LEARNED THAT
SIXTY ONE PER OF LICENSE ENTERS
AND SIX POINT 5% OF LICENSED
FAMILY CHILD CARE HOMES. HAVE
CLOTHES DO YOU DO CODE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC- THE YOU KNOW THE
QUESTION THAT WE ALL HAVE BEEN
IN LEAGUE. IS WHETHER OR NOT.
OPEN AND BUT WHAT A- I'M WE
STILL WERE THAT. 7% US AND SIX
POINT FIVE PERCENT- EACH OF
THOSE- CENTERS WILL. OR WILL
OPEN AND TO THAT EXTENT BUT DO
WE HAVE ANY IDEA NOW I KNOW THE
GOVERNOR MADE ON SOME
ANNOUNCEMENTS TODAY- FOR IT FOR
CHILD WILL BROADLY BUT
INCLUDING AYE CHILD CARE
CENTERS TO DO WE ANTICIPATE
WHAT THE WHAT THE EXPANSION
MIGHT LOOK LIKE IN THE NEXT.
FEW WEEKS. YES THANK YOU THIS
IS JESSICA AGAIN FROM THE
NEED WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
ANNOUNCEMENT TODAY WAS THAT WE
RECOGNIZE THAT. THERE IS AN
IMPORTANT IN GETTING I'M CHILD
CARE FACILITIES AS WELL SCHOOLS
BACK ONLINE IN ORDER TO
SUPPORT- OPENING BACK UP THE
ECONOMY. AND CAN'T GO BACK BACK
TO WORK UNLESS THEY HAVE CARE
FOR THEIR CHILDREN- SO WHAT THE
GOVERNOR WAS INDICATING WAS AND
THAT WE ARE STARTING TO LOOK AT
WHAT IS GOING TO BE NEEDED- ON
IT. IT IS THE PHYSICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE IN ORDER TO HELP
SUPPORT CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
OPENING AND GETTING THEM ACCESS
DISH ACCESS TO CARE- SO THAT
THAT IS WHAT IS SIGNALING AND
WE DON'T CURRENTLY HAVE- A LOT
OF. DETAILS TO SHARE BUT- IS
THE NAY STEP ARE SAYING IN THE
NEXT FEW WEEKS. THANK YOU AND I
THINK AS THOSE PLANS- BECAUSE I
MET AS YOU'LL UNDERSTAND MORE
DETAILS ABOUT THE PLAN AND ALSO
TIME LINES I THINK FOR US AT
LEAST FOR ME I'M KNOWING ANTI
WHITE TIMELINE OF WHEN I CAN
EXPECT SOMETHING- HELPS US
UNDERSTAND IS THIS A MATTER OF
WEEKS OR MONTHS BEFORE WE HAVE
CERTAIN INFORMATION- I THINK
WOULD BE HELPFUL BUT I
APPRECIATE. THE FACT THAT
EVERYONE'S DOING AS MUCH AS I
CAN THIS OF THE MANY ISSUES-
THAT WE ARE FACING IN THE STATE
AND- I APPRECIATE THE EFFORT
THAT'S BEING PUT INTO THIS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. OKAY.
QUESTION BACK HERE IT WAS ONE
QUESTION OUT GALLAGHER HE'S
STEPPED OUT. IN THE INTERIM LET
ME ASK ONE MORE QUESTION FROM.
A CD OR TWO MORE QUESTIONS
RIGHT HERE. AS FAR AS THE- AS
FAR AS THE RATIOS FOR- FOR IF
YOUR FEET YOUR KIDS OUT HOW
WILL THAT WORK FOR THE
FINANCIAL VIABILITY OF THE
PROGRAM SAYS FOR CD. THANK YOU
FOR ASKING THAT I STAND. HERE
THIS IS THEIR NUMBER MARKET
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF THAT SO.
AS YOU INDICATE. WITH THAT NEED
FOR SOME SOCIAL GUIDANCE AROUND
MASTER SOCIAL DISTANCE SCENE WE
HAVE DECREASED GREAT SIZE. AT
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES AND PUT OUT ADDITIONAL
GUIDANCE ON THAT SO FOR OUR
DIRECT CONTRACTED PROGRAMS
THEY'RE BEING HELD HER LESS SO
AS THEY PROVIDE THEIR CARE
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO GET LAST.
FINDING REIMBURSEMENT BASED ON
THE NUMBER OF CHILDREN THAT
THEY'RE SERVING AS WE KNOW THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE MUCH
SMALLER GROUP I SAID. AS WE
LOOK AT OTHER PARTS OF OUR
PROGRAMS. ACROSS THE STATE
NAME. AND SERVICES I THINK
YOU'RE RIGHT TO INDICATE THAT
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WILL
BE. STATION ON OVERTIME. WHAT
IS THE LOOK LIKE FOR THINGS
LIKE A REGIONAL MARKER RATE
WHAT COST IS. REALLY HER AT THE
LOOK AT SMALLER GRIP SIZES BUT
I WOULDN'T HAVE ED DIRECTORS
STREET YUP WHAT WE'RE RIGHT
NOW. BRECHT ACTED BROWN'S. LIKE
THIS JUST LEAVE TO YOU TODAY
WITH. PANEL YES IT WAS THE
HEARING. DAYS ASSIST BLUR SO
YESTERDAY WE HAD A GENTLEMAN
WHO WAS THAT PRESIDENT CEO THE
SAN FRANCISCO CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE TALKING ABOUT
RESTAURANTS. AND HE WAS SAYING
THAT IF ALL THINGS GO WELL.
THEY CAN OPEN UP THE
RESTAURANTS IT'S GET FRANCISCO
WOULD HAVE ABLE CAPACITY I
THINK HE SAID LIKE TWENTY TO
FORTY PERCENT. AND HE WAS
SAYING THAT. THAT'S NICE TO GET
CUSTOMERS BACK IN BUT IN
REALITY THEY NEED TO HAVE THEIR
RESTAURANTS AT A HUNDRED
PERCENT. TO JUST ABOUT. RIGHT
THEN TO MAKE MONEY WITH ALL THE
COSTS THEY HAVE PAGES ENSURE SO
WITH SO. TO SAY THING THE
CENTER BASED PROGRAMS WE TALKED
EARLIER ABOUT THE THEIR
REIMBURSEMENT RATES WITH WHICH
WE ARE INADEQUATE WORK ON
LEGISLATION TO ADDRESS THAT I
TALKED ABOUT EARLIER WITH
DOCTOR ALL AN ACT. AND SO WE
HAD THE MINIMUM WAGE DIRECTIVES
AND THE RATE STRUCTURE SO. OUT
THIS KIND OF LIKE THE
RESTAURANT IF YOU IF YOU WERE
KIDS IN YOUR- IN YOUR- HOME
CENTER. HOW'S THAT
MATHEMATICALLY PENCIL OUT WHAT
WILL WHAT AM I MISSING HOW'S
THAT GOING TO WORK IT SEEMS
LIKE IT'S NOT GONNA WORK. AND
THIS IS THEIR NUMBER MARKET
AGAIN YOU'RE ASKING SOME REALLY
GOOD QUESTIONS THAT OUR TEAM
HERE IS ALSO. WRESTLING LAND I
THINK AS WELL AS THE
ADMINISTRATION THE RIGHT
THERE'S ALWAYS FIXED COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH OPERATING A
PROGRAM SO WHAT YOU BROUGHT UP
SOME OF THOSE FIXED COSTS. I
KNEW IN THE PAST THERE BEEN
INNOVATIONS SUCH AS TWILIGHT
PRO GROUNDS DIFFERENT THINGS
THAT I THINK ALL OF US TOGETHER
ARE GOING TO HAVE REALLY
INNOVATIVE. AROUND OUR I DO
NEED I AN OPENING BACK UP AND
WHAT DOES THAT LOOK LIKE AND I
COULD TELL YOU RIGHT NOW
EXACTLY. I JUST NEVER REALLY.
THIS AND- WITH ALL OF YOU HELLO.
AS AS WORKING MINISTRY. TO FIND.
POLLUTION DURING WHAT WE KNOW
IS ALSO GOING TO BE AN
EXTREMELY CHALLENGING BY THAT
TIME. YEAH I THINK THE REALITY
HERE IS THAT OUR LAST HEARING
WE TALKED ABOUT. IS THE- NOT
REAL. BILL AT. THIS TO EXPAND
ACCESS WE'LL BE LUCKY TO GET
MONEY AND THROUGH. FEDERAL
MONEY THROUGH OUR ONE TIME
RAINY DAY FUNDS IN THROUGH
DEFERRALS AND SMOKING HERE'S
TACK TACTICS OF SOMEBODY MAY
SAY JUST TAKE KEEP WHAT WE
HAVE. STABLE UNLIKE THE LAST
RECESSION WHERE WE CUT- WAS A
HUNDRED THOUSAND. SLOTS AND
NEVER GOT THEM ALL BACK AND SO
WE DON'T WANT TO DO THAT- SOME
ARE DWINDLING JUST. BECAUSE THE
VIABILITY PROGRAMS AS WELL AS
WE HEAR TODAY. SO IF YOU LOOK
AT THIS IF YOU IF YOU HAVE A
PROGRAM. THAT HAS YOUR KIDS YOU
EITHER. BY DEFINITION WILL
SERVE FEWER KIDS AND SQUEEZE
OUT FAMILIES AND RATION ACCESS
OR YOU'LL HAVE TO CABS
ADDITIONAL MONEY. TO SUPPLEMENT
BECAUSE IT'LL COST MORE TO HAVE
THOSE RATIOS LOWER AND I DON'T
KNOW WHAT IT IS LAW MONEY COMES
AND SO. HOW DO WE RECONCILE
THOSE TWO THINGS WITH. NOT
WANTING TO LIMIT ACCESS AND
SQUEEZE OUT. SQUEEZE OUT
FAMILIES AND- MAKE SURE THESE
THESE PROGRAMS CAN CAN PENCIL
OUT. FINANCIALLY. SOUNDS LIKE
YOU'VE BEEN IN THE ROOM WITH
THAT SAID WE STRUGGLE WITH SOME
OF THE SAME REALLY HARD CHOICES
AND THE A LOT OF THIS IS TO BE
MADE MOVING FORWARD BUT WE'RE
REALLY HAPPY TO BE PART OF THAT
CONVERSATION AND CONTINUE DON'T
COME THROUGH ALL OF OUR DATA.
WE DO NOW AS WE MOVE FORWARD
SOME OF THE THINGS TEN FAST ARE
A REALLY STRONG DATA SYSTEMS
THAT WE CAN BE MORE RESPONSIVE
MORE QUICKLY AND BE ABLE TO
TELL YOU WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE
ACROSS THE STATE WE ALSO KNOW
THERE'S WAYS TO YOU NOT. AS
QUICK BACK TOGETHER THE SAME
SYSTEM THAT HOW DO WE BUILD
EVEN STRONGER SYSTEM AND TAKE
THAT OPPORTUNITY TO ENSURE THAT
OUR WRITERS WHETHER THEY EAT
HOME BASED ON BASED HAVE WHAT
YOU NEED SUCCESSFUL AT THAT.
OKAY YOU SIR I NOT THE IN THE
ROOM WHERE IT HAPPENS WITH THIS
DISCUSS ABOUT OUR CRACK STAFF.
AIRING GABLE FROM- THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE- IS AND WILL BE SO.
THANK YOU WANT ONE FINAL
QUESTION. BACK TO THE- THE THAT
PP GEAR THE QUESTION IS HAS
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
ADMINISTRATION PUTS SCHOOLS IN
CHILDCARE ON THE ESSENTIAL PP
RECIPIENT LIST. IS THERE SUCH A
LOT. THIS IS JUST GONE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- I'M NOT
FAMILIAR WITH THAT LIST I AGAIN
LET ME CHECK IN WITH MY
CONTACTS OVER IT YES AND I
WILL- SEND SOME RESPONSES BACK
TO YOU AND YOUR STAFF. OKAY
THANK YOU I BELIEVE THAT WRAPS
IT UP FOR COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
QUESTIONS ON THIS ON THIS PANEL
HEARING NONE AND NOW WE'RE
GOING TO AGAIN GO TO THE PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION PIECE OF THIS AND
ONCE AGAIN THERE IS A- THAT A
NUMBER YOU CAN DIAL IN THE
NUMBER WILL WILL BE ACROSS THE
SCREEN A FEW SECONDS BUT ALSO
JUST TO REPEAT IT'S.
1-877-692-8957. ONE EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. ACCESS FOR FIVE
THREE TWO ZERO. FOUR EIGHT FIVE
THREE TWO ZERO. SO AGAIN WE'RE
ASKING THAT THE INDIVIDUALS ON
THE LINE TO GIVE US YOUR NAME.
ORGANIZATION OR AFFILIATION IF
YOU HAVE ONE. AND PLEASE KEEP
YOUR COMMENTS TO ONE MINUTE OR
LESS SIXTY SECONDS OR LESS. SO
WITH THAT WE WILL PROCEED WITH
OUR PUBLIC COMMENT THANK YOU.%
RIGHT ONCE AGAIN IF THERE ARE
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE PRESS
ONE BUTTON ZERO AT THE TIME.
AND WE DO HAVE A COMMENT COMING
FROM THE LINE UP WITH THE NAME
COLBERN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS THE MAIN MICHELETTI
COLBERN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAM
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
NUMBER MCCARTY AND NUMBERS FOR
THE TERRAIN. I'D LIKE TO
SUPPORT THE TESTIMONY OF DOCTOR
MICHAEL ALL ONE NECKING
CATHERINE GALLONS BIG PROVIDE A
GREAT CONTACT FOR TODAY'S
HEARING. I TOO WOULD ASK A FAIR
NEVER MORGAN COMMENT THAT
FAMILIES CURRENTLY ENROLLED IN
CARE HAVE NOT LESS THAN TWELVE
MONTHS THE CHILD CARE. FOR THE
FAMILY TO HELP MONTH IS DUE UP
FOR RE CERTIFICATION. IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH CD WITH THE
PORT AGENCIES TO DEVELOP A PLAN
TO ADDRESS THE RECERTIFICATION.
FOLLOWING KEEPING THIRTY. I
WOULD LIKE TO OFFER A HUGE
THANK YOU TO TD HEFOR TAKING A
PROACTIVE APPROACH TO REALLY
THINK. 3% OF ALLOCATE FIFTEEN
TO HELP QUARTER VOUCHER
PROGRAMS WITH STABLE FUNDING.
WE ARE THANKFUL DURING THE
EMERGENCY OF POLICY ELIMINATING
VARIABLE WORK SCHEDULED FOR
PROVIDERS SO THAT THEY KNOW
WITHOUT A DOUBT HOW MUCH MONEY
THEY WILL GET REGARDLESS OF
WHAT THEIR- FAMILY AND CHILDREN
GO. MOVING FORWARD WE NEED MORE
FIRST SNT TO WORKERS PASSED IN
THIRTY AS THE ESSENTIAL WORKERS
THAT WE WILL. ONLY WILL NOT
HAVE SCHOOL OR SUMMER SCHOOL TO
GO BACK TO WE NEED TO RECOGNIZE
THAT FAMILIES NEED THE CARE TO
SUPPORT THEIR SENSE OF WORK AND
EARLY MORNING HOURS AFTER HOURS
AND KEEP ME IN AND WE- CAN
MOVING FOR ME OUT. THERE THANK
YOU THEY AND- WELL I. WENT TO
AM. CUT OFF PEOPLE AFTER WHAT.
TO KNOW THAT IT'S NOT ME
CUTTING YOU OFF IT'S THE- BAD
TECH PEOPLE. THE ROOM SO I'M
NOT THE PERSON SHOPPING THE
APP. TOPPING THE LINE OFF SO
BUT I WILL NOTE THAT THEY THEY
DO DO IT. AND SO PLEASE DON'T.
HAVE IS HOW TO DO IT SO KEEP
YOUR COMMENTS TO SIXTY SECONDS
OR LESS THANK YOU. AND THERE
ARE NO ALL COMMON PUBLIC
COMMENT IN THE QUEUE AS OF
RIGHT NOW ONCE AGAIN THAT IS
ONE THEN ZERO. I THINK WE HAD
TWENTY A SECOND AGO. ON THE
LINE. OKAY HUH. WELL WAIT A
SECOND BECAUSE I KNOW THERE ARE
QUITE A FEW VIGILS WHO WANTED
TO PARTICIPATE. OKAY SO IF YOU
WANT TO IF YOU'RE ON THE LINE
AND YOU WANT TO COMMENT MAKE
SURE YOU. PRESS THE-
APPROPRIATE BUT NOW WHICH IS
WHAT. DO YOU CAN YOU REPEAT
THAT ONCE AGAIN. OUR OUR
MODERATOR ONE THEN ZERO YES ONE
ZERO YOU'RE ON THE LINE ONE
THEN ZERO TO GET IN THE QUEUE
TO COMMENT. YEAH I WOULD ASSUME
THAT WE HAVE PEOPLE LINE UNLIKE
THE PRIOR GROUP OR- HOUSTON
JUST SO WHAT WILL BE A LITTLE
MORE FLEXIBLE HERE SO. NEXT
NEXT INDIVIDUAL PLEASE PROCEED.
I SAW NO PUBLIC COMMENTS IN THE
QUEUE AS OF RIGHT THIS MINUTE.
RIGHT WE HAVE A PUBLIC COMMENT
COMING FROM THE LINE OF JESSICA
FENDER PLEASE GO AHEAD. MCCARTY
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HOLDING
UNION MEMBERS WITH THE
TECHNICAL STANDARDS FROM EQUAL
RIGHTS ADVOCATES AND ALSO
REPRESENTING THE STRONGER
CALIFORNIA ADVOCATE. COALITION
VERY MUCH SO AT THE CORNER LOT
OF THE COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE
AND STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE-
COALITION IN TERMS OF
PRIORITIZING- HOW CAN THE
BUDGET. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THAT COMMENT PUBLIC COMMENT
COMES BACK THREE NORTH THE
THOUGHT HAD. HI THANK YOU
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE-
APPRECIATE YOU HOLDING THIS
HEARING I'M CALLING BECAUSE THE
GOVERNOR- ISSUED A STATEMENT
THAT CALIFORNIA PLANS TO. USE
SOCIAL DISTANCING SCHOOLS TO
AVOID A RESURGENCE OF COME
NINETEEN ROOMS BECAUSE WE OPEN
FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
SCHOOL YEAR. THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF SCHOOLS THAT ARE SLATED FOR
PERMANENT CLOSURE AT THE END OF
THIS SCHOOL YEAR. IT DOESN'T
MAKE SENSE FROM A FINANCIAL
PUBLIC HEALTH. EQUITY
STANDPOINT TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
THE PERMANENT CLOSURE OF THE
SCHOOL. CLOSING SCHOOLS SEVEN
FIVE- CROWDING MORE STUDENTS
INTO FEWER SCHOOLS WILL ALSO
MAKE IT HARDER TO GET PHYSICAL
DISPENSING. AND LASTLY CLOSING
SCHOOLS HAVE HURT LOW INCOME
BLACK AND BROWN FAMILY FIRST
AND BARS. BOB FIGURING OUT
WHERE THEIR KIDS WILL HAVE TO
GO TO SCHOOL IN THE FALL IS THE
LAST THING FAMILIES NEED TO ADD
TO A GROWING LIST OF CONCERNS
AROUND HOW. FINANCE HAVING
ENOUGH TO EAT. AT ACTION THE
OPEN- AND AT HAS BEEN NOTED WE
KNEW MAY NOT EVEN BE ABLE TO
KEEP ALL OF THE CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS OPEN AND WE CAN AND
MUST BE PUBLIC SCHOOLS OPEN
DURING THIS CRITICAL TIME.
WHERE IT SHOULD BE A CENTERS
FOR OUR CRITICAL RESOURCES AND
SERVICES I'M A PARENT ABOUT
FOLKS TO OAKLAND UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT. CHILDREN AND ALSO THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OUR BAKER
CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS. AND THE NEXT PUBLIC
COMMENT COMES FROM A LINE OF
ROSANNA CARBOXYL PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BROADBAND I YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. WE WILL GO TO THE
NEXT LINE WHICH IS BARBARA
GLAZER PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
BARBARA GLAZER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
WE UNDERSTAND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE MUST TAKE ACTION TO
DISTRIBUTE THE CARE OF FACT
FUND TEMP RESPECTFULLY OFFER
THE FOLLOWING FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. FINANCIAL
SUPPORT ARE ESSENTIAL WORKERS
IS A CRITICAL PART OF ACCESSING
A NETWORK THAT CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS FLEXIBILITY IN
SELECTING THE APPROPRIATE CHILD
CARE IS ALSO AN IMPORTANT
CONSIDERATION. TRADITIONAL
CHILD CARE SETTING MAY NOT BE
THE BEST CHOICE DURING THE COLD
AT NINETEEN PANDEMIC THEREFORE
WE ENCOURAGE THE CREATION OF
ADDITIONAL VOUCHERS PLOT THAT
ACCOMMODATE THE NET NECESSARY
FLEXIBILITY FOR OUR E. CENTRAL
HAVE HEALTHCARE EMPLOYEE. WE
REQUEST THAT ANY PROGRAM
UTILIZING THOSE FUNDS BE
CREATED IN SUCH IS TO ALLOW
FAMILY SELECT A CHILD CARE
PROVIDER THE STATUS I CHILDREN
SAFE EDUCATIONAL NEEDS IN IS
AVAILABLE DURING NONTRADITIONAL
HOURS. AS WE LOOK TO THE SUMMER
MONTHS THAT WE SHOULD CONTINUE
TO SUPPORT OUR CENTURY
WORKFORCE BY PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL OUTREACH BEYOND JUNE
THIRTIETH MANY CAMPS AND
COMMERCIAL. FOR BEING SESSION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. CONNECT
PUBLIC COMMENT COME SOME MARTY
ALL MODEL PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY
THE MOTO FAMILY MEMBERS AND CAL
BELIEVE SENIOR ACTION NO
PROJECTED ON THE PERSON ACTIVE
BOOK BUT I JUST REALLY WANT TO
THANK GOD THAT HE MEMBERS. AND
ALSO THE STAFF FOR DOING THIS
AND ALSO HAVING THE BUT THAT IT
IS A GREAT OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL
OF US. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OUR
NEXT PUBLIC COMMENT COMES FROM
JUST BEING FLORA PLEASE GO
AHEAD. TO MAKE YOUR THEIR SHIP
ALL RIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
TESTING. HI MY COMMENT IS THAT
FIFTY SIX OF 56% OF FAMILY
CHILD CARE THEY'RE CURRENTLY
OPEN THE QUESTION WAS THAT.
WHAT CAN BY MUSLIM WORLD WHAT
CAN WHAT CAN YOU DO TO ME OUR
NAME FIRST OFF- OR NOT BE NAY
KNOWLEDGE CHILD CARE NOT BEING
IN KNOWLEDGE FAMILY CHILD CARE
IN PARTICULAR ARE NOT BEATING
KNOWLEDGE THIS IS WHY A LOT OF
FAMILY CHILD CARE PROVIDERS ARE
TURNING AWAY RIGHT NOW THEY
FEEL THEY- THERE'S NO ONE.
BOARDING THAT WE'RE NOT
RECEIVING THE SUPPORT WE NEED
AT THIS POINT NOBODY'S
COMMUNICATING WITH US WE ARE
RECEIVING CALLS ON A WEEKLY
BASIS HOWEVER GOAL CALL THERE
JUST TO ASK THAT. OUR
AVAILABILITY ARE WE OPEN. AND
AFTER EXTEND EAGLE THAT IS NOT
SUPPORT- WE NEED AT PART PP WE
DO NEED SUPPLIES WE DO NEED ALL
OF THAT HOWEVER WHAT WE NEED TO
SUPPORT WE NEED SOME
REASSURANCE WE NEED. THAT'S NOT
TO UNDERSTAND THAT FAMILY CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS ARE NOT JUST
BABY SITTERS WE ARE EDUCATED
AND WHAT WE WANT IS. WE WANT
SOME OF GRANT WE WANT TO GRANT
MONEY TO. HELP US FURTHER
EDUCATION SO THAT WE COULD
CONTINUE IN THIS BILL TO EXPAND
TO GET INTO TEACHING TO GET US
INTO FURTHER EDUCATING. OUR
YOUNG. MIND OUR YOUNG CHILDREN
THAT ARE COMING FOR THE FUTURE.
BACK UP. THE NEXT PUBLIC
COMMENT COME FROM MORE THAN A
CALLBACK SO PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON YOUR LIBERTY AND-
MEMBERS I APOLOGIZE FOR THE
TECHNICAL- PROBLEMS EARLIER OF
DIRECTED BY THE MODERATOR TO
HANG UP SO IT IS NOT- NOT
TALKING TO YOU ALL- SO AGAIN
WE'RE GONNA COME OUT HERE ON
THE HAVE TO EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION CONSORTIUM THERE ARE
COALITION OF THE LARGEST MULTI
STATE AND MULTI SITE CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS IN THE COUNTRY- EASY
EASY CONSORTIUM MEMBERS HAVE
OVER SIX THOUSAND LOCATIONS IN
FORTY EIGHT. STATES AND
COLLECTED SERVER MILLION
CHILDREN IMPLORED A HUNDRED AND
SEVEN FIVE THOUSAND EARLY
EDUCATORS IN CALIFORNIA ALONE-
IF YOU SEE A CONSORTIUM MEMBERS
OPERATE APPROXIMATELY FOUR
HUNDRED HIGH QUALITY CHILDCARE
CENTERS. AND THAT YOU GOT
DISCUSS A THEY'RE- PROVIDER CAN
AND HAVE BEEN VERY HARD HIT.
BUSINESS IS BY THE CORONAVIRUS-
CRISIS. YEAH I'M SURE ALSO OF
IN FORTY FEDERAL BACK. DROP THE
NEEDS OF. FINAL CHILD CARE
CENTERS AS THEY WERE COMPLETELY
LEFT OUT OF THE FELT REALLY
EACH PACKAGE. SO HAVE YOU ON
THE QUESTION TODAY I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THAT- BUT ALSO
REMIND YOU THAT AS WE'RE
LOOKING AT- RE OPENING THE
ECONOMY AND THE LIMITS ON GROUP
SITE AND THAT THAT'S GONNA.
WILL EAT THE ABILITY TROUT. WE
MAY VIABLE AND CERTAINLY. OF
THE BILL TO REACH TO THE PRIOR
PROVIDED THAT THEY WERE WENT
PRETTY KOPEN. I JUST LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR
TIME AND CORPS OF THE REALLY
GREAT QUESTIONS THIS AFTERNOON
AND JUST REMIND YOU THAT. I'M
OUT OF CALIFORNIA DOES BEGAN TO
RE OPEN THE ECONOMY THAT CHILD
CARE THE NECESSITY. THAT WILL
NEED TO BE HERE FOR A FAMILY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ONCE
AGAIN FOR PUBLIC COMMENT THAT
WOULD BE ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
PHONE. AND WE DO HAVE A PUBLIC
COMMENT FROM THE LINE UP ON
THE- YET BAILEY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE I'M
A PARENT AND A TEACHER IN
CALIFORNIA. AND I JUST WANTED
TO SAY THANK YOU FOR HAVING
THIS MEETING- I WANTED EVERYONE
TO TAKE INTO ACCOUNT BUT THE
GOVERNOR SAID. THAT HE WANTED
TO HAVE GREATER SOCIAL
DISTANCING IN SOME DISTRICTS IN
CALIFORNIA. SCHOOLS ARE
ACTUALLY BEING PERMANENTLY
CLOSED. THEY'RE BEING LOCATED
OR MURDERED STAND SO I WOULD
ASK THAT YOU ALL TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION THAT THE STATE.
BECAUSE AND SOMEHOW- URGE THE
GOVERNMENT TO DO THE SAME.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME HAVE A
GREAT DAY. AND OUR NEXT PUBLIC
COMMENT COMES FROM THE LINE UP
JESSICA BACK DOWN YOU KNOW
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN JESSICA. YES CAN I SPEAK
NOW. YOUR LINE IS OPEN. OKAY MY
NAME IS JESSICA MANDELA NOW AND
I'M NOT FAMILY CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS IN THE CITY OF FIVE
AND OF CALIFORNIA AND- I THINK
YOU FOR GIVING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO THE
RIGHT AND BEHALF OF FAMILY
CHILD CARE. WE WILL LIKE TO ASK
YOU. WELL ACTUALLY I WANT TO
TELL YOUR FAMILY TO GET
PROVIDERS. SUPPORT OUR WE WANT
THIS BOOK FOR. TO CONTINUED
WORK FORCE OF TO DAY WHILE
PREPARING THE WORKFORCE OF
TOMORROW. FINALLY CHILD CARE
GENERATE SIGNIFICANT ECONOMIC
TO RETURN. AT FIFTY ALLOWED
STANDS TO ENTER AND REMAIN IN
THEIR WORK FIRST AND PROVIDERS
TO INCREASE THEIR OWN EARNING
AT THE BUSINESS OWNERS FAMILY
CHILDCARE PROGRAMS ARE THERE
FOR PROVIDING CRUCIAL EARNING
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE
CHILDREN THAT MEANS THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES THE MALL.
INCLUDED IN FRANCE AND HOLDERS
IN CHILDREN WHO PARA THE
WORKING NONTRADITIONAL HOURS AS
TO ASK IS HAPPENING RIGHT NOW
WITH THE CRISIS. HIGH QUALITY
FAMILY CHILDCARE HAS BEING
LINKS DOING. TO IMPROVE MANNING
CHILDCARE PUBLISHER. SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL AND PHYSICAL
DEVELOPMENT MORE OVER IS
STUDIES HAVE SHOWN. THAT THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR ONE ON ONE
RELATIONSHIP UNDER EXPLOSIVE
FURNITURE ENVIRONMENT FOUNDING
FAMILY CHILDCARE SHOULDN'T HAS
THE POTENTIAL FOR POSITIVE
OUTCOMES FOR CHILDREN SO WE ARE
I'M ASKING YOU TO PLEASE
SUPPORT FAMILY CHILD CARE WHILE
YOU WHAT- I HAVE THE ABILITY TO
DEAL THANK YOU AND TO HAWKINS
CAN BIG. BUSINESS THANK YOU.
OUR NEXT PUBLIC COMMENT COMES
FROM THE LINE OF MARY YOU MAY.
NOT MATIAS HOW MANY NEED MERRY
HUMANA- I WORK AT TI AND MIGHT
CENTER CURRENTLY HAS THIRTY
NINE SANDERS CLOSE AT ONE OF
THE BIGGEST- INDUSTRY OKAY A
FOR CHILD CARE PROVIDERS MY
BIGGEST QUESTION IS HOW ARE WE
GOING TO. CAN YOU TO HELP OUR
WORKERS ARE TEACHER I THINK
WHAT CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
PARENTS WRITING WORK I AM NOT.
HOW ARE WE GOING TO PROTECT OUR
EACH OUR TO HELP THE BALLOT.
AND HOW ARE WE GOING TO REPAY
THAT WORK THAT THEY'RE GIVING
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW AS WE ALL
KNOW THE THIS WORK FOR YOU. SO
MUCH FOR US. HE IS NOT MEETING
THE MAN OF THE WORK AND SO
THAT'S ONE OF MY BIGGEST
WORRIES RIGHT NOW. HOW DO WE
KEEP THEM SAFE AND HOW DO WE
SHOW THEM THAT WE DO APPRECIATE
THEM. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME DAVE. AT OUR NEXT
PUBLIC COMMENT COMES FROM THE
LINE OF RON OF RAP PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER GERALD LAMBERT RON
WRAPPED. UP THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS OF OUR
NUMBER ONE PRIORITY IS TO
PROTECT OUR STUDENTS IN
EDUCATION EMPLOYEES AND SURE
THAT WE CONTINUE TO. PROVIDE A
HIGH QUALITY EDUCATION WE DID
SUBMIT A VERY COMPREHENSIVE
LETTER ON APRIL SEVENTH HE-
OUTLINED ERIC SPECIFIC BUDGET
RECOMMENDATIONS BUT I JUST WANT
TO COMMENT ON THE OF. THE EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION P. VERY
INFORMATIVE- HEARING THANK YOU
SO MUCH- AS AS WE HEARD TODAY
IN MANY PARTS OF THE STATE DAY
CARE AND EARLY EDUCATION
CENTERS HAVE BEEN FORCED TO
CLOSE TO ASSIST WITH THE CODE
NINETEEN EFFORT. THE NEGATIVELY
IMPACTED GRAY NUMBER OF PARENTS.
PUBLIC EDUCATION EMPLOYEES- WE
BELIEVE THAT WE NEED PROVIDED
ANOTHER MONEY SO THAT WE CAN
AND- MAINTAIN THE CAPACITY OF
THE EARLY CHILDHOOD- PROVIDERS.
TO REMAIN OPEN AND SO WE'RE
WE'RE REQUESTING THAT YOU- TAKE
A VERY CLOSE LOOK AT THAT
PROVIDE THE DOLLARS NECESSARY
TO- THE THING THAT CAPACITY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER AT.
INTERNET PUBLIC COMMENT COMES
FROM THE LINE OF ROSANNA
CARBOXYL PEOPLE HAD. JUST
DOUBLE DIPPING. SHE IS BY
MISTAKE I THINK THAT WAS THAT
YOU MIGHT WANT TO VIEW YOUR
LINE. ROSANNA ABOUT JOE. OKAY
SHE DROPPED ALL I HAVE TO
OTHERS WAITING TO GET THEIR
NAMES.
OKAY SAID IT AND WE HAVE
A PUBLIC COMMENT COMING FROM
THE LINE OF MELISSA CORPS BURN
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN OKAY.
MELISSA YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON I WANTED
TO THANK YOU FOR TAKING PUBLIC
COMMENT TODAY AND I ALSO WANT
TO CREATE YOUR AWARENESS ABOUT
CONCERNS THAT- PARENTS IN
CALIFORNIA HOW THE L. RELATED
TO SOCIAL TO SOMETHING- WE KNOW
THAT WHEN SCHOOLS REOPEN- THIS
IS GOING TO BE A CONCERN. AND
BECAUSE OF THAT THE GOAL REAL
SHOULD BE TO MAXIMIZE THE
NUMBER OF FACILITIES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE I HEARD YOUR CONCERN
FROM YOUR EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION FOLKS ABOUT PUBLIC
SCHOOLS ARE OTHER STILL
POSSIBLY TAKING OVER THEIR
SITE. ON IT ONLY MAKES SENSE
DURING THAT TIME TO KEEP ALL
SCHOOL OPEN IN OTHER WORDS TO
STOP CLOSURES TO STOP MERGERS
JUST STOP CO LOCATION SO THAT
OUR CHILDREN CAN BE STATE- IN
THIS UNCERTAIN TIME AND I ALSO
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO DO THAT
FOR ABORTION TO DOUBLE PAID.
KIDS SO I'M HOPING THIS
COMMITTEE WILL CUT DOWN. UNDER
ADVISEMENT THANK YOU. AND WE
HAVE ONE MORE PUBLIC COMMENTS
COMING FROM THE LINE OF EL
BUDGET GIPSON YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. THANK YOU- THIS IS
OFFICIALLY KANSEN DIRECTOR OF
PUBLIC POLICY FOR CHILD THREE
SIXTY AND GOOD AFTERNOON I TEAR
MCCARTY- WE KNOW THAT
HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONAL TO
PROVIDING ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL
SERVICE RIGHT NOW. FOR CHILDREN
OF THE CENTRAL WORKERS BUT I
FEEL LIKE I'D BE REMISS IF I
DIDN'T ALSO NOTE THAT I'M EVEN
PROVIDERS WHO HAVE BEEN FORCED
TO CLOSE THEIR DOORS. ARE
CONTINUING TO SUPPORT FAMILIES
AS TERRIBLE MORGAN MENTIONED
WITH HOME LEARNING ACTIVITIES
INFORMATION ABOUT GRABBING GO
COULD BEING. ADVICE ABOUT HOW
TO KEEP CHILDREN LEARNING AND
IT'S A TESTAMENT TO THEIR
DEDICATION AND INDICATIVE THE
FACT THAT THERE CRITICAL NOT
ONLY TO THE ECONOMY BUT ALSO TO
OUR EDUCATION. INFRASTRUCTURE I
ALSO WANTED TO ECHO THE HUGE
NEED FOR SUPPLIES- SO WE'RE
EAGER TO SEE HOW THE FIFTY
MILLION- WILL BE ALLOCATED- MY
ORGANIZATIONS FROM LA COUNTY
AND WE- WERE VERY EAGER TO
RECEIVE THOSE FUNDS. AND ALSO
WANTED TO SAY THAT WE'RE
GRATEFUL THAT THE LEGISLATURE
ACTED SO QUICKLY IN PASSING SB
ONE SEVENTEEN AND FEEL THAT.
EXTENDING THE HOLD HARMLESS
PROVISION THROUGH FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE WILL HELP
PROVIDE MEASURE OF STABILITY.
FOR THE CHILD CARE WORKFORCE
NEEDS TO CONTINUE DOING THE
VALIANT WORK- THAT THEY HAVE
BEEN AND ALSO THAT ENSURING.
THE NEW FEDERAL TCG DOLLARS ARE
UTILIZED TO PROVIDE CONTINUED
SUPPORT PERSON TO WORK FOR-
WILL WILL GO. FAR AS WE CAN
EXPECT A. DOLLARS THANK YOU HE
ALSO. AND WE DO NOT HAVE ANY.
ONE ELSE IN YOU. WERE COMMON.
ONCE AGAIN THAT IS A ONE THEN
ZERO. I DO HAVE A COUPLE LINES
QUEUING UP HERE. YEAH. WELL
THEY'RE NOT PROFESSIONAL AND
THE NEXT PUBLIC COMMENT COME
FROM OLD BELLY UP MEDINA. YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON SURE MCCARTY AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- I'M CALLING
ON BEHALF OF FIRST FINDING
WHERE MEMBERS A HOUSTON BUT YOU
CALL IT AND I JUST WANTED TO
SHARE A COUPLE OF THREE
REQUESTS THAT I BELIEVE MY
COLLEAGUES OPPOSITE ALREADY-
OVERALL WE'RE ASKING THAT WE
ALLOCATE THAT THREE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION OF THE NEW. THE
FUNDS TO PROVIDE. ONE FULL YEAR
OF OPERA FOR INCOME ELIGIBLE TO
WORK FOR IT AND I REFUSAL
DRAIN- ARE. ARE ALREADY
MENTIONED THAT- THAT FIFTY
MILLION OUT OF THE GOVERNOR'S A
HUNDRED MILLION ONLY COVERAGE
ROUGHLY ABOUT. TWO TWENTY
THOUSAND FIVE TO NOT ONLY FOR
TOO MUCH- WORLD ASKING FOR THE
EXTEND TO EXTEND THE TUCKER
PROVIDER CALLED FROM THE
PROVISION- TO TWENTY TWENTY- WE
ARE YOU KNOW A LOT OUR- OUR-
OUR PROVIDERS ARE NEEDING A
THIRTY DAY HOLD HARMLESS
PROVISION RIGHT NOW. UNTIL IT
WILL GIVE PROVIDERS AND IF
YOU'RE TRYING TO- TO. MEET
THEIR NEEDS AND FINALLY WERE
ASKING TO REPURPOSE ONE TEN
MONEY THAT WAS ORIGINALLY BUT-
AT. THE VERY TOP TEN PEOPLE
PROGRAMS ON IT IS ESTIMATED
THAT THE CD HAVE ABOUT. EIGHT
HUNDRED MILLION TO ONE BILLION
IN ONE TIME FUNDING THAT
ORIGINALLY BUDGET FOR VARIOUS
HEALTHCARE PEOPLE PROGRAM. I
WOULD RECOMMEND YOU KNOW WE-
MAY BE SALAS FRANK THINKING OF
THE WHEN YOUR WHOLE TIME. AND
MANY OTHER ITEMS ALREADY
ALREADY. MENTIONED TODAY THANK
YOU. IN OUR NEXT PUBLIC COM.
COMES FROM THE OF G. MARK HEY
BEFORE HEADLINE IS OPEN. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS JENNY
MOE HIGH AND THE DIRECTOR OF
EXTERNAL AND GOVERNMENTAL
AFFAIRS THAT HAD THAT
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU FOR I'M
HAVING THE HEARING THAT FOCUS
ON THE IMPACT OF THAT NINETEEN
ON OUR ON OUR KIDS- AND
FAMILIES DURING THE CRISIS. HAD
STARTED EARLY HEAD START AT THE
LADIES HAVE CLOSE- AND THERE
ARE SOME HEAD START PROGRAMS
THOUGH THAT ARE ABLE TO BE
OPENED SERVING CHILDREN A
POTENTIAL WORKERS IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH LOCAL
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS. AND
DESPITE BEING AT NOT BEING ABLE
TO OFFER ON SITE CARE THE
CLOTHES I HAD START SITES ARE
CONTINUING FOR CHILDREN FAMILY
THE MODIFIED CARE BECUSE LIKE
CHECKING IN WITH FAMILIES
DROPPING OFF- THE CARE
PACKAGES- AND DELIVERING HOME
LEARNING PACKET THAT GOAL
REGULAR SESSION NATIONAL
ACTIVITIES ONLINE. AND WHILE
HEAD START PROGRAMS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE A FEDERALLY
FUNDED PROGRAM MANY AT START
PROGRAMS YOU. ADMINISTER RIGHT
NOW SHIP WITH RUN. SO WE- AS
SUPPORTTHE FIFTY AT. THE TO
INCREASE I AM SORRY THAT COULD
BE MILLION DOLLARS BE CLEANING
SUPPLIES AS WELL AS THE AND
INVESTMENT IN AT. DISEASE HE
BEAT THE DVD DO FINE FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND
HOPEFULLY THAT HELPS SUPPORT.
INCLUDE OFFERING HOW DO PAID TO
ANY EARLY CHILDHOOD WORKER
CARING FOR CHILDREN THE
POTENTIAL WORKERS BECAUSE WELL
AS AN EQUITY INVESTMENT IN
TECHNOLOGY AN EARLY CHILDHOOD
PROGRAM THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THERE ARE NOT PUBLIC COMMENT
COMES FROM A LINE OF JENNIFER
CRAPPIE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH
HI THIS IS JENNIFER CRAPPIE
WITH VOICES CALIFORNIA AND OUR
THIRTEEN CHAPTERS ACROSS THE
STATE ARE URGING- THE COMMITTEE
AND THE GOVERNOR TO- USE THAT
THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS BUT THE CITY BG FIVE.
TO PROVIDE ONE YEAR OF FULL
TIME CARE FOR THE FAMILIES WHO
HAVE ALWAYS BEEN ESSENTIAL MANY
OF THEM HAVE BEEN ON A CHILD
CARE WAITING LIST FOR YEARS-
AND THEY'VE BEEN PROVIDING
THIS. ESSENTIAL WORK FOR OUR
STATE FOR. ALWAYS AND SO- I AM.
ASKING THAT YOU. AT MAKING.
AVAILABLE TO THE FAMILY THANK
YOU. AND ONCE AGAIN LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN THAT IS WORN IT BENDS
THEIR OFFER A PUBLIC COMMENT.
AND WE HAVE A COMMENT COMING
FROM THE LINE OF NO NOT
BOUTIQUE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M
HI THIS IS NINA BEAKY FROM
EVERY CHILD CALIFORNIA FIRST
OFF I WANT TO THANK THE
ASSEMBLY FOR THE HEARING TODAY
REALLY APPRECIATE. I'M HEARING
THAT CHILD CARE AND EARLY
LEARNING IS ESSENTIAL IN SO
MANY WAYS DURING THIS CRISIS- I
THINK BOTH IN SERVING CHILDREN
AND HEALTH CARE FRONT LINE AND-
AND- ESSENTIAL WORKERS BUT AS
WELL AS KEEPING THE ECONOMY
GOING. AND KEEPING THE
INFRASTRUCTURE OF THE EARLY
CARE AND EDUCATION SYSTEM BOTH
ELLIE AGE PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
PROVIDERS. WE ARE ALSO VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE FIFTY
MILLION FOR THE EMERGENCY ABOUT
YOUR CARE AS WELL AS THE FIFTY
MILLION FOR A DEEP CLEANING
SUPPLIES- I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO.
THANK ALL OF YOU FOR PRE TO THE
FOREFRONT BUT THE REIMBURSEMENT
RATES FOR SUBSIDIZED EARLY CARE
AND EDUCATION PROGRAMS BUT THE
REGIONAL MARKET RATE AND THE
STANDARD REIMBURSEMENT RATES.
WHICH ARE TO THIS CRISIS WAS
GROSSLY INADEQUATE IT'S REALLY
SHOWING ITSELF RIGHT NOW TO BE
INCREDIBLY INSUFFICIENT TO MEET
THE NEEDS OF THESE. CENTRAL
PROGRAMS AND COURT. THE VERY
INTENSE WORK OUR DUTY DURING
DESK INCREDIBLE TIME. A WE
WOULD LIKE TO ECHO SOME OF THE
SENTIMENT BUT OTHERS WERE
SAYING AND SUPPORTING OF AN
EXTENSION TO HOLD ARE LOOKED.
UP TRIED PROVIDERS WITHOUT
CONTRACTS FLEXIBILITY IT. WOULD
NOT BE ABLE TO REOPEN IT
CONTINUE TO STAY AHEAD OR
MANAGE THE NEW STOPPING RATIOS
TO COMPLY WITH SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS.
CURRENTLY ACROSS YOUR MATH
TWENTY FOUR PART DEEP CREEK
LODGE IN OPERATING A HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY FIVE DAYS A YEAR
GENERATE. WITHOUT NINE. RAISE
YOUR LIMITING PEN TO ONE COST
BUT ONLY CHEN FIFTY FOURTH
DOLLARS A YEAR AS SUCH WE NEED
NAY H<c.cyan>ARMLESS GET PROVIDERS</c>
TO OFFER FIND A CLASSROOMS HEY
EVEN IF SOME OF THEIR CHILDREN
ARE UNABLE TO ATTEND DUE TO
ILLNESS I WANT TO THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR THIS HEARING- I THINK
AGAIN ESSENTIAL MORE NOW THAN
EVER WE NEED ALL OF OUR EARLY
CARE AND EDUCATION PROGRAMS I'M
TO BE SUPPORTED LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH ALL IF YOU ASK ME
MAYES BOARD. THANK YOU AGAIN.
THANK YOU. OUR NEXT PUBLIC
COMMENT COMES FROM A LINE OF
MARIE ATARI PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME'S MOVIE ALLUDES PROGRAM
THE ORGANIZER OF THAT ONCE
SOMEONE CISCO THANK YOU FOR
HOLDING THIS HEARING. AND I
TOTALLY SUPPORT THAT YOU SEE
BUT JUST ASK FOR CHILD CARE-
MANY OF OUR FAMILIES WHO ARE
ALREADY MARGINALIZED I THINK
OUR TO ONCE OR GETTING. PUSHED
OUT OF THE AND NOT INCLUDED AND
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO. TO
HOME IT NEEDS TO BE FAMILIES
MANY OF THEM ARE SOCIAL
WORKERS. AND ARE NOW UNABLE TO
WORK AND BEING A CHILD CARE TO
GO BACK TO WORK THANK YOU SO
MUCH. OUR NEXT PUBLIC COMMENT
COMES FROM A LINE OF MARY IT
NADIA PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS MERRY IGNATIUS WE FINALLY
FIGURED OUT HOW TO GET INTO THE
QUEUE- I JUST WANT TO REITERATE
THAT COMMENT BUT MY COLLEAGUES
AND REINFORCE THAT DATA THAT
DOCTOR OLD MAKE SHARED ABOUT-
THE NUMBER THAT THE NUMBER
FAMILIES WHO ARE CURRENTLY
BEING SERVED YOUR CHILD CARE
ASSISTANCE. THE MAJORITY ARE
SPECIAL WORKERS THAT THE
MAJORITY OF FAMILIES WHO ARE ON
AND- THE CENTRALIZED
ELIGIBILITY LISTS ARE ESSENTIAL
WORKERS AND MAJORITY ARE WOMEN
OF COLOR THIS IS REALLY A-
GENDER RACIAL AND ECONOMIC
JUSTICE ISSUE THAT WE ALL HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS. AND
SO WE'VE ALSO WORKED WITH THE
LEGISLATURE FOR THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS TO REALLY.
DECLARE THE IMPORTANCE OF
TWELVE MONTHS- CONTINUITY OF
CARE AND SO FAR SOCIAL WORKERS
WHO ARE GETTING THESE EMERGENCY
CARE VOUCHERS WE HAVE TO. WE
CAN'T YOU KNOW AFTER ALL THE
WORK THEY'VE DONE THEN JUNE
THIRTIETH SAY SORRY YOU NO
LONGER YOUR- YOUR- WORK YOU DO
AND THE CARE YOU NEED IS NO
LONGER SHOP. I THINK THAT WOULD
JUST BE AN INCREDIBLE SLAP IN
THEIR FACE AND SO WE NEED TO
USE. EVERY DOLLAR THAT'S COMING
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
EVERY DOLLAR THAT HAD NOT BEEN
BANNED- BUT HAS BEEN ALLOCATED
FOR CHILD CARE IT WAS REALLY
GOOD TO HEAR THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SAY THAT. NEED DOLLARS
CANNOT BE SUPPLANTED SO WE HAVE
BY BEING LET'S FIND THE
SOLUTIONS AND MAKE SURE WE'RE
TAKING CARE NOT ONLY OF OUR
CONTROL WORKERS THANK YOU AND
THESE ARE WORKING FAMILIES BUT
OUR CHILD CARE WORK. HE'S ON
THE- AND SACRAMENTO COMES FROM
THE LINE OF THREE D. GARDEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI YES MY NAME
IS TRACY AND I AM A PARENT OF
TWO CHILDREN WHO ATTEND OPEN
PUBLIC SCHOOLS CURRENTLY AND
ARE CITY OF OAKLAND- THE SCHOOL
BOARD IS FOCUSING ON MAKING ART
SCHOOL BIGGER- THE GOAL WAS TO
HAVE SIX HUNDRED. PLUS CHILDREN
IN ONE SCHOOL- THIS DOES NOT
WORK IN THE WORLD OF CODED
NINETEEN I WOULD REALLY URGE
THE GOVERNOR TO MAKE AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER TO STOP ALL
SCHOOL CLOSURES. PERMANENT
SCHOOL CLOSURES MERGERS
COLOCATION- THIS IS NOT THE
TIME TO INCREASE OUR CLASS OUR
SCHOOL BY THE TO SIX HUNDRED
PLUS CHILDREN NEED TO KEEP THE
FACILITY THAT WE HAVE WE NEED
TO SOCIALLY DISTANT AND WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THERE ARE
EMOTIONAL THERE ARE CHILDREN IN
MOTION. BEING IS ALSO MET WITH
THE COAT NINETEEN THIS IS BEEN
VERY TRAUMATIC FOR OUR CHILDREN
HAVING THEIR SCHOOL PERMANENTLY
CLOSED AND LOSING FAMILY
MEMBERS TO COVET NINETEEN WE
REALLY NEED TO PUT THAT
PRESSURE ON THE GOVERNOR TO
MAKE THIS EXECUTIVE ORDER TO
STOP ALL. MERGERS CALL OKAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND ONCE
AGAIN THAT IS ONE ZERO FOR A
PUBLIC COMMENT. WE DO NOT HAVE
ANYONE IN Q. AT THE TIME. OKAY
THANK YOU. WITH THAT WE ARE
GOING TO CONCLUDE- THE PUBLIC
COMMENT FOR THIS HEARING- WE
THANK EVERYBODY FOR
PARTICIPATING TODAY YOU KNOW WE
SENSE LEE I THINK THAT THIS IS
A KEY ISSUE RELATED TO THE
RECOVERY HOW WE FOCUS ON OUR
KIDS OUR SCHOOLS OUR
COMMUNITIES AND CERTAINLY OUR
CHILD CARE SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA
AND IT'S ALREADY FRAGILE WE
KNOW THAT WE'VE BEEN FGHTING
FOR IT EVERY YEAR IN THE STATE
BUDGET AND NOW EVEN MORE SO IN
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE TAKE STEPS
TO- TO PROTECT THE SYSTEM TO
PROTECT CERTAINLY. FAMILIES AND
PARENTS WHO ARE TRYING TO GO TO
WORK AND MAKE SURE IT WILL
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THESE EASY
PROGRAMS ARE CRITICAL TO MAKE
SURE THAT KIDS ENTER
KINDERGARTEN READY TO LEARN SO.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND OUR STAKEHOLDERS.
TO ADDRESS THE ISSUES. THAT WE
KNOW. IN THE KOBE TWO MONTHS
GOING BACK BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY
WHEN WE COME BACK AND VOTE ON
THE STATE BUDGET. IN MAY AND
JUNE MAKE SURE THAT THESE
ELEMENTS ARE PART OF OUR VALUES
THAT WE- INCLUDE OUR STATE
BUDGET GOING FORWARD- SO WITH
THAT WE WILL ADJOURN TODAY'S
HEARING. THANK YOU SO MUCH. BUT
OUR CONFERENCE FOR TODAY THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION IN.